Makina immedion.
Are we live?
Sure,
yeah.
Do ustream dot TV forward slash
big Jay Z.
Jay z here.
Bam.
And I'm tweeting and we're like,
what the fuck?
Big Jay.
Welcome back,
sir.
I heard you were punching white people in Baltimore.
Is that true?
He just ran around just punching white people.
Well you got to get all of the fans you can get right?
If you want to be down one way right now.
Be Super upset with white people.
I had a,
I had an argument with a comic about Baltimore.
Uh,
this week.
I was like,
he was very pro,
like the
okay.
The violent protest of it.
White Dude white like hipster white comic I would say.
And His.
I was so surprised because I always thought they were supposed to be the tender
guys and his comment like I couldn't believe the coldness and him saying he was
like so big fucking deal that,
you know,
they tear apart a,
a cvs.
He goes,
who gives a shit?
Man,
there's people getting killed in the street now the cops are killing people in
the streets.
And it's like,
who cares?
Like the fucking owner of the CVA.
Like why?
What does he have to eat shit for it.
It's totally unrelated.
They did it in Ferguson to businesses that were owned by black people.
I mean there was,
there were some instances of people burning down businesses that had absolutely
nothing to do with any of the pro police,
you know,
group.
There were people that just lived in the community and then all of a sudden
everything got smashed in Oakland.
When when some guy,
the guy got shot in Oakland,
there was a,
they smashed up bank and someone wrote fuck capitalism on it.
Like,
okay.
I really like.
Is that what this is about?
The fucking cop killing the guy is about Canberra.
Is it the other one that the accident or the quote unquote accident at the train
station?
Yeah,
that was fucked.
Did you see the movie they made of it?
No.
They made a movie of it.
I like when they do this with a lot of Hollywood stuff that it's sort of
hilarious.
Phoned in thing was if you remember,
if you remember the biggie smalls movies,
you ever see that one ever saw it.
What was it?
Did you say?
If I.
no,
it's called notorious.
Played Bass actually was pretty good.
That previewed look like he did a good job.
Jamie.
Pull up a fucking Prius
I guess,
but what was funny was the night he died in the movie,
like he made phone calls to everyone and he's like,
I'm going to be good too.
You told his mom that money gets.
They didn't always like things that are not true in that fruitvale station
movie,
which is about the Oakland guy.
Like they literally made that day like,
you know the guy,
he sold drugs for Kima given drugs and he was like,
Nah,
I don't want to do this shit no more better with my daughter.
And the thing is like,
you know,
the comedian named Chris Tinkle,
I pointed out because he knew the story.
He's from that area and he said he was like,
it's already tragic.
Anyway,
this is a tragic situation where a kid got killed.
Whatever was going on,
he probably deserves to get killed by a cop accidentally or otherwise,
so it's just like,
why would you have to add like a.
and he was going to go back.
He was going to go to University of Phoenix.
Online dues.
I can.
I can
spell it out.
Nice and simple.
It's exactly what it is.
There's a very high percentage,
a very high percentage of the movie business that's filled with wonderful
creative people.
Fantastic.
Folks that just want to make good movies.
Like ex Machina.
I saw x walk into this big Holy Shit.
Is that good?
God Damn.
That's amazing.
Special effects.
Was it one of those movements?
The best movies I've ever seen in my life and I don't want to say anything more
about it.
We'll talk.
We'll talk about a little bit but,
but,
but points,
most of them are trying to do shit like that,
but there are a few out there and those ones will stand out and they will just,
they will just fucking,
just in every soup you gotta add their little fucking spoon to all your ideas
and they fuck everything up man.
And especially it's grows especially gross when they do a real live story.
A lot of times they'll do who are still alive and they just butchered this toy.
Like that fucking wrestler movie.
What the fuck was that?
We've talked about it before.
What is it called?
Fox catcher fucks the one about John Hunt or what?
Hunt?
John.
Mark Hunt.
No,
no,
no.
Margaret has a fighter.
My contract.
What is the guy's name or pharmaceutical company?
Yeah,
John Dupont.
Dupont.
Thank you.
John Dupont,
who was a crazy murderous cocaine fiend who shot this wrestler.
Dave Schultz,
who's a famous wrestler,
but the movie's about his brother,
Mark Schultz,
who's still alive and you just add a bunch of shit to it.
Make a bunch of shit up,
change the timeline around.
Change the success story of his life.
Also also throw some kind of like a gay undertone for no reason.
Coke doing coke with a Gig for you to get frosted tips and short shorts.
The whole thing was like,
what's going on here?
What are you doing,
man?
You know,
it's one of the methods because I'm from Philly and that story happened in
Pennsylvania outside of Philadelphia and it was Connecticut,
Fox catcher things in Philly that was outside of Philly,
Pennsylvania.
Oh Wow.
Confused.
But I think it was John Du Pont.
It was like a multiple day stay.
Also.
One was interesting.
It was that it was a standoff for days with the cops,
but they made it like he killed the guy and then he walked out of his house and
they just arrested him like it was such like a speed through all the things that
are real and interesting to add some weird Hollywood like they have to force in
the fact that maybe he was gay for this guy.
They had nothing to do with anything.
Just decided to make them gay.
Just to make this more fun.
You're going to get me arrowhead and my helicopter
helicopter on each other's sweating.
Do they change shit that they didn't have to change,
like historical shit,
like the fact that he was already a world champion,
one of the best wrestlers on earth.
They made him out to be like a guy was failing and falling apart.
They also had him fight in the UFC,
did fight once in the UFC,
but against a white guy in a real UFC.
Fought against a black guy named big Gary Goodrich.
It's a historic match.
It's a historic,
like if you're a.
If you're a martial arts historian that matches the historic match because he
was an Olympic gold medalist.
He came and just took down one of the best mma fighters at the time at will and
show the difference between like worldclass wrestling and this fucking bullshit
that these guys were doing in the gym.
They were.
They were infants in comparison to his wrestling skill,
but they changed the timeline of it.
They had him watch the UFC and 87.
The UFC wasn't even made until 93,
so they just fucked with everything.
Just to gay it up and add a little of this
little fucking.
Yeah.
That was my idea is basically the script man.
The story structure just didn't work.
There was something missing.
Gay stuff.
When they get.
When they get those actors,
they don't want to like it to just be in independent film theaters,
so they gotta they got Hollywood,
some horse shit story into it all.
It's just so.
It's so depressing.
They do that to a movie.
That's a real story because then you have in your head,
oh,
well we almost got gay with the guy.
He did coke,
he saw the UFC and 87.
You have all these things in your head and then you start reading and you go,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
That's not the case.
Like there was.
He wrote a list on facebook.
Mark Schultz did have all the inaccuracies of the foxcatcher movie.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
They just been fucked with everything they know because he was like a consultant
on the movie.
I'm sure he probably knew a little bit.
What the fuck is he going to do?
They're probably given him an ass load of money,
right.
Tips.
He say he's a wrestler.
Wrestling coach at Brigham Young.
I mean he had a stop mma fighting because the school that he was teaching
wrestling at didn't want them doing it.
It was a different time.
It was like 96 or 97 or whatever the fuck it was when he fought.
That was right on the end of like USC being like sumo wrestler fights in Ninja.
It was still that still.
He was still using bare knuckles.
There was still a,
I think he would still wear shoes when I started used to google wear shoes.
You couldn't punch the balls when I first got there.
You couldn't punch the balls and you couldn't.
I don't think you could pull hair anymore.
They got rid of that early on.
Fun growing up.
I watched a documentary recently to a 28 USC 20 and like,
uh,
having that go through my life,
like watching this sport grow in my lifetime for me,
I remember me and my stepfather order the first one ever when it was tournament
style and you have to go out and fight like three times and we thought it was
like the greatest thing of all time.
But data watch it go from like,
you know,
no shoes,
no,
Geez,
no gouging,
all these things.
But you have to,
that has to happen.
And then they go,
oh Yay.
Now you can't just,
you can't just break a guy's finger because you're losing.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's why can't you,
if you break guys arm,
how come you can't break but what guy's finger like?
I really,
I disagree with like all the thoughts about like small joint manipulation
because the reality is if someone's trying to manipulate your joint,
like if say the only way that would really.
The only way that usually works in defense,
like say if a guy,
if you're a,
you're trying to grab a guy and you're trying to choke him and he starts pulling
on your fingers,
well you could just pull your fingers away,
you know,
it's not like it's an automatic that he's going to break your fingers.
Sure.
You just have to be more aware of it.
Like it's realistic.
Like if a guy has to do is pull your finger back to stop you from doing a choke
will.
Then he did the right thing.
Why are you taking that away from him when it's okay for him to choke you?
Oh yeah.
You have to like actually get under the hand itself completely.
Right?
But why are you taking away the guy's ability to pull on your fingers?
Yeah,
we've pulls on your fingers.
You better get your fingers out of there and then try to choke them again.
It just makes sense to me.
I actually thought because it never happens that I thought there was a rule of
no choking in the UFC,
like a direct on choke.
Like you're trying to fight against the wall,
but you can do that.
Apparently it's the most unrealistic move to this same reason.
No one headlocks like you did in the school yard as a kid where you have the guy
got a bulldog position.
Him as like the more that nef that so rarely ever happened to us.
I think you're wrong.
I think it is illegal to grab the neck like that.
I think it's illegal to straight on.
I think it used to be legal,
but now it's illegal.
I need.
Yeah.
I need to find out about that.
There was something about,
well,
there's a bunch of weird spots that you can't do.
Like do you know you can't hit a guy in the back of the head,
can't hit a guy in the back.
You get kicked in the back of the head all the time.
When you get hit with a head kick.
One of the things about a head kick is you know the shins kind of coming around
here and a lot of times like a high percentage,
that foot in the instep are bang wrapping right around the back of your head way
fucking harder than you can ever punch like so.
The idea that you don't get hit in the back of the head,
it's crazy because there's a totally legal shot that's basically the back of the
head.
Nobody ever gets in trouble for kicking somebody in the back of the head and it
happens all the time.
It's just ground and pound.
When you're grounded.
Impounding is usually when guys get in trouble for hitting the back of the head,
which is the most ridiculous because that's when guys are moving around.
He's trying to protect them.
All we gotta do is get to the back of your head,
but standup wise,
a lot of guys get hit in the back of the head.
They get hit with clubbing punches like when in like in melees.
They never get in trouble for that and there's a lot of elbows that go to the
back of the head because you're up against the cage and in areas where you'd get
in trouble hitting him somehow and ground and pound,
it seems almost like elbows to the back of the head and punches the back of the
head are really only recognize clearly when it's ground and pound wha.
Why Man?
What was that?
Uh,
to Diego Sanchez elbowing the top of clay.
Sweetest head.
Like I don't know how those weren't like illegal.
Excuse me by the rules.
That should have been illegal.
Here's the top is fine.
It's the base of the skull that's supposed to be the real danger area.
It's the back of the head and the base of skull.
You can elbow top of the head was directly on top of the head is fine.
The top of the heads find the sides of the head are fine and there's like a
bunch of debate about like,
what is the [inaudible] called?
The Mohawk,
the Mohawk,
meaning this is the area that can hit Mohawk in the back of the head like that
strip down with a spine is some people extend it more towards the ears and some
people keep it more narrow and some people lower it,
so it's just the base.
Some people think that like right here,
like sort of the mid back of the head,
it's fine,
so it's,
it's,
it's open to debate,
but the idea is ultimately that the base of the spine is very dangerous to hit
and then if you hit someone they're really hard.
You might be able to separate their fucking brain and our spinal column.
It was a big move in the old day.
See,
in the old days,
one of the best moves was you'd take guys back and then you would smash the back
of his head with elbows like Henzel Gracie did that too.
Like this judo specialist that he fought and got.
I want to say like,
I forget the organization.
It might have been Mars or it might have been like one of those,
one of those like really,
really young old school martial arts promotions that never really made it so
Hensville gets this guy down,
kitces back and just fuck it.
Boom.
Just smashes the back of his head because it's totally legal back then and you
realize like that takes away all your rear naked choke,
all that stuff.
That's like not even nearly as effective as doing that.
You've got a guy's head fee.
If you're.
You got him face down and you're smashing the back of his head with elbows while
you have the back mountain.
There's very little he can do to defend that used to be illegal.
It's funny in that unit goes to.
They take away from the sport.
It still stays a thousand times more interesting than box.
You see,
man,
everybody says that.
Right?
But I really found that fight interesting.
I'm of the minority that thought that it was a really interesting fight.
Everybody was mad for this.
With that,
I'm like,
come on.
You.
As a person who appreciates boxing,
that fight to me was pretty wild.
It was intense to watch because you know manny Pacquiao,
he's been able to get his gloves on everybody.
He fights everybody.
He fights,
he lights up,
he gets a hold of you.
Eventually any lights you up and you might get them like mark has got them,
but before market has got them sound like pack.
Y'All didn't crack them,
you know,
they weren't going back and forth and back and forth.
Just smart cast as a legendary Chin and awesome punching power and eventually
knocked pack,
yell out.
But pack yellow is in these wars with Margarita wars with Kodo,
you know,
just bash the shit out of Chris.
Algeria is real slick and moves real well.
Just gets you.
And he's a pretty boy.
White Guy.
He's a pretty boy,
white guy,
but he's a bad motherfucker,
but manny Pacquiao just could not get to floyd.
Then one time he did get them.
It's like nothing,
you know,
it's like floyd just covered up,
uses defense,
kept shaking his head like,
nope,
nothing.
Nope.
Nothing like manny.
We just couldn't get them.
To me that was impressive as fuck the way he was moving.
Like every time manny would come for that blitz,
floyd was gone.
He just wasn't there,
you know,
just suit super slick boxing.
I'm from Philly,
so I spent a lifetime with Bernard Hopkins just watching him and rooting for him
of these,
these really long,
slow flights.
They are like,
they just take for us.
I think floyd mayweather was kind of the same thing for me.
You know,
I just watched again man,
that you see that Tyson documentary on cable all the time,
which is him sitting and talking in the,
in the white shirt when they go to that footage.
Once in a while I'll even watch that.
Fox Sports,
we'll do the,
you know,
the all day just Tyson's fights,
but watching that footage of him training and just how fast he wasn't what he
was doing.
How come there isn't.
There hasn't been the Mike Tyson since my Tyson.
There's been arguably six Jordan's since Jordan.
You know what I mean?
You need a lot of things that come together correctly to make a Mike Tyson.
You need a lot of things.
Also that talent,
I think in the last decade jumps to mma.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know man.
I don't know.
I mean there's still a lot of guys who really like boxing.
You know,
I,
I got an,
a famous argument years back with this guy,
Lou Dibella on espn where I was telling the box he was going to get swallowed up
by the,
by the UFC,
by MMA,
by a more dynamic sport,
but I would have never done that if that guy wasn't a dick.
But I like boxing.
I've always liked boxing.
I've been a huge fan since I was a little kid.
Man.
Just always been a fan of it.
There's some.
I also am a big fan of kickboxing.
I'm a big Fan of glory and I'm a big fan of Moitai because I think that there's
things that you pull off in just straight kickboxing or boxing,
that you just can't do an mma because guys will clinch you the three to the
ground.
You just,
you can't get it off.
You can't do most of this shit.
Floyd mayweather does with leg kicks,
soon as leg kicks were in the mix.
You can't do most of this shit,
but to me what he's doing is incredible.
I mean it's so artistic.
He's beating the game.
He's going out at 48 F and o with no brain scrambles me.
There's only been tagged that I can remember twice,
three times at maximum.
Never been really fucking battered to the point where you like,
the fight is going to be stopped and he's to come back like goddy ward or
anything like that.
None of that shit.
But if you're going to stay interested in boxing now you have to be a real fan
of like the sweet science.
You know what I mean?
Like the quote unquote because there's just no.
I mean there's just not.
People want to see knockout,
you know?
At the end of the day we're all,
I guess the gladiator cage and we don't want to see like,
you know,
people get knocked out.
You want to see that violence that you like.
MMA is such a scary thing to the layman that boxing's become less scared.
She's like,
we'll go to the size of those gloves,
like these guys are going multiple rounds and they're getting hit with,
you know,
it was like a sponge over your fist a little bit,
like,
yeah,
let's do it.
I think it just like draws.
You can't go back with attention more.
You can.
I can,
I don't,
I really,
I mean I'm not just saying here's what,
here's what you'll never.
You'll never have a girl will never go retroactive from UFC to boxing.
I don't think so,
but,
but you can get a girl girls very easily.
I find getting the UFC really.
I think girls get into UFC very,
very easily.
What do you think that is that some gladiator gene shit,
they want to get some gladiators permanent.
I think there's an actual.
Yeah,
I think there's like the,
the,
I think the,
like the machismo of the whole thing.
And then also uh,
in UFC very specifically,
but in,
in most of the televised mma stuff,
I actually really,
I mean UFC really does it like the best.
Like if you just give your girl two episodes of the buildup shit like Daniel
Cormier,
Jon Jones,
like she was in,
she invested interest in that because we watched it.
I made her go back watch Jon Jones.
Like first thing when he came out,
he was the hero.
She put her out of this course.
Uh,
yeah,
I want to say about it made her watch that,
you know,
that half hour thing of him like,
I saved the old woman from getting robbed and I was thinking she and his story
and it's kind of hard luck story and growing up.
And she was like,
wow,
I really liked this guy.
Them again watches things now.
Like he just,
his personality is different and he just made himself like the villain sort of.
Well,
I don't think that the villains,
I think villains in actual sports,
so not wrestling.
What's funny about that?
I think any kind of sport actually like,
you know,
even someone who hates the Yankees,
like if you meet a rod,
you're probably still like Mr Rodriguez,
as you know,
you're,
you're meeting like a sports celebrity to some degree.
You know what I mean?
Like I'd always say like fuck Michael Jordan,
like I'm not like a bulls fan of,
but it'd be amazing to meet Michael Jordan,
you know what I mean?
Don't you think?
Right now's a great time to get chicks into a two because of Ronda Rousey.
Like there's never been never been a female fighter.
Like Rhonda Rousey a hot check the pizza fuck out of everybody,
but she's so hot and she really assisted video of her
with Luke rockhold and she's got Luke rockhold and what we call spider web.
It's when you try to finish Armbar,
Luke rockhold is a fucking monster.
Okay.
He's like six,
300.
He cuts down to one 85 is usually way over 200 pounds.
He's a fucking stud at Jujitsu and Rhonda are.
She completes the arm bar on him like he's defending,
like he's really defending and she completes it and he has to tap.
That's how bad ass she is.
Like I don't think,
you know,
like if you,
if you've never been armed guard before,
you don't know how ridiculous that is.
Like a guy that grew,
caught luke rockhold,
she'd have like retarded defense,
like he's an ace level MMA black.
But look,
look at this.
This is Luke rockhold on the bottom here.
Okay.
Luke rockhold again is world class in the UFC at 185 pounds.
Just beat the fuck out of Leo Machida,
I mean,
destroyed him,
took him to the ground,
controlled him,
smashed him,
finished out the Brown and here he is trying to defend against Ronda Rousey's
arm bar and she's got a bunch of different techniques she uses to uh,
attack the grip that he's using.
She keeps adjusting.
Readjusting.
Now I see how he stepped over her head right there.
That's like fucking defcon four.
Like he knows he's in some serious trouble could if she straightens out his arm,
he's done and he's got a tap.
And she seconds away from straightening out his arm and he's going to get to
this situation is tap,
tap,
tap.
He had a tap.
She fucking tapped him.
Dude,
she fights at 1:35 as a woman.
He fights 50 pounds heavier as one of the best men in the world.
That that's how fucking good her arm bar technique is.
There's never been a fighter in any fucking sport like her before.
No.
That's like a total pioneer because she's the one before her,
like her.
She,
she so impressed me on that last one with cats in Ghana.
Yeah.
Because I know it was over in 14 seconds,
but watching it just in real time,
I was like,
that was a series of lucky things that worked.
Effort and live in that position.
And then.
No,
no,
no.
And then when she said it,
she said in the,
in the interview she have been working on that,
doing the transition.
You don't borrow from that transition and she,
uh,
and then when you watch it in slow motion,
you see her make a fucking decision to step over.
But it was one of the craziest things I've ever seen.
Yeah.
She's,
she's terrifying and she's fun and she's not like a,
you know,
Cyborg was terrifying,
but so much because of the size.
It wasn't like any kind of a necessary.
I mean she had a skill set,
but it wasn't that,
that was so,
it was just like she was 10 times bigger than that,
you know,
kind of like a man.
Yeah.
I mean let's be at her height way worse than China.
Wait,
why did we decide big why's?
She was like the side,
but it was different because you are getting to see her actually hit people like
in China was really impressive because she was big and strong and you're like,
I,
she,
uh,
she was on fear factor.
Like China's yoked.
I mean,
she's a big girl.
If she,
you know,
if you had to wrestle her a goddamn tussle,
that's a big Gal,
you know,
she's strongly sex tape with wrestling.
Stop Pussy boner.
That's total wrestling.
Did you watch the one where she did anal fro one within ones?
It was mostly pro launched.
If she'd have professional porns portfolio apart,
but you're still one where it's a back door to China on it.
You did it and I remember having a little bit,
but it was like a really famous porn dude went for poor bastard.
Both of them.
I don't know.
But um,
but my point was like,
when she,
you're not supposed to say the sideboard looked like a man,
but when she was beating the fuck out like Gina Carano,
she was feeling like a man.
It wasn't like the classic female body type.
So when she got busted for male steroids,
everybody's like,
of course she looks different now though,
man,
she's,
she's become more feminine,
a lot more feminine.
But there's,
there's an honest debate as to what,
how much of how much of what you do to your body when you alter it that
severely,
how much you changed this permanent.
Like they've done these studies on athletes that have taken anabolic steroids
and um,
they've had permanent effects on the strength,
permanent,
not just temporary but permanent,
like permanent improvements in strength.
And so they wonder like,
how much of her getting off the male hormones?
Like how much does she lose?
Does she lose all of it?
Is it still fair?
I mean,
what,
what is it?
I don't know.
You know,
my,
uh,
my stepfather,
I think it's a pretty naturally strong guy,
but he did a bunch of steroids when he was younger.
Power lifting,
that's what he did.
And uh,
you know,
even through his forties and he,
he's in his fifties now.
Like,
like I can still go out there and bench on just a day,
throw up like 350 pounds.
I mean I remember it 30.
He's like doing like 4:55 and,
and he's not,
he always like,
you know,
a buck 70 bucks,
75.
Yeah.
Those power lifter dudes,
man,
that's a totally different type of moving your body.
That's like some severe strength that's required to do.
But I'm saying,
but the steroids,
I believe like definitely you still,
you still build a base,
you know,
the thing is what happened.
I think it raises your base.
It doesn't mean to according to these studies,
but the question is it gets more complicated when it's a woman because it's not,
it's not even like she took like more of what she already had.
She actually introduced some stuff that she's not supposed to have.
I mean,
you do have a little bit of testosterone when you're a woman,
but nothing like the levels that they take when they get into bodybuilding or
power lifting.
Like the women that like even track and field women
people get get caught all the time taking shit because it works.
I mean it changes their.
You ever seen like bodybuilder porn,
like girl bodybuilder,
Porno,
nude pictures.
Like,
oh,
it's a man's body.
I was watching one of those,
uh,
those are my strange addiction shows and the lady that was addicted to
bodybuilding and she,
her sister was on as a point of reference.
It was really interesting.
Like,
your sister's like,
you're getting bigger.
Are you going to keep getting bigger?
She's like,
I just love it.
This is what I look like now.
I love it.
I can't wait.
I'm on how well you know,
how often do you work out?
And she's like,
oh,
I work out like three days a week.
She's like,
I work out seven hours a day.
She was working out six,
seven hours a day.
Her fucking head was as big as Tito Ortiz's and my mood together.
She's a giant fucking neck.
Huge traps.
Look at this broad.
Is that her?
Is that the one from the show yet?
Look at the size of this lady.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's me and I'm the years ago,
maybe 2005 or something of 2006.
Me and Patrice to the nasty show in Montreal together and after the show there
was a bodybuilder chick who was white girl way into him and really thorough and
she was.
She was just saying stuff like,
so sexy to own.
Patrice was so weird.
I mean you didn't do anything with it,
but I remember him saying he was like,
he goes,
I might just have to wrestle it as big bitch.
I was with a Jujitsu girl once.
That was very intimidating.
Yeah,
but that's it.
She's a regular size gal.
She's an actual.
This other one,
I don't know if you know about that was a different one.
Yeah,
there's been with three Jujitsu chicks before.
One was definitely bigger than the other ones and she just had one of those big
bodies and I remember her vagina was very clean and like no hair but yet had
that explosion of Pussy,
lips,
Brown Pussy Lips.
They give us like a midi vagina and it was weird.
It was a weird.
I've never even fucked a chick with abs.
I don't think ever had one gal that was a bodybuilder when I was like really
young.
I think I was 21 and a day.
This gal from New Hampshire had a six pack.
It was weird.
Had its rear body though.
Her legs were incredible.
I mean that like an like those bodies and dresses look great.
Sometimes the girls just like abs,
like bodybuilder.
I was just like a girl who's like toned and strong,
but looks like a girl.
Like there's a difference in the girls strongholds.
Who girl or a guy like no fence.
The lady in those photographs was most likely on some male hormones.
I mean,
you get the fuck out of here.
That's Vito Belfort in Brazil.
I mean that's.
Look at the size of that chick.
She looks like Mark Coleman when he won the heavyweight title,
but you can even put that male hormone is why their faces.
That wasn't the face she was destined to have.
No,
she has a man's face.
Yeah.
She's very manly.
Mean like monster.
Like it's really weird touching a girl also when it's hard as a rock and not
like soft and she and.
But I mean,
okay,
here's the question.
Is that better or worse than someone who eats themselves into a gelatinous wall
of meat?
I would take fat over that whale.
Like for a Gal,
for your lady friend.
Fat Chicks we're going to come up with are awesome.
Yeah.
I would hook up.
I'd hook up with A.
I mean for the ones,
for the storage,
I'd go that direct life.
You think like if you could get her off the sauce,
she could probably woman up a little bit.
Right?
Much.
How much would she woman,
but she would still retain a bunch of it,
you know,
I know because there's a gal that lives in my friend's neighborhood and I go to
visit him and she was apparently some Olympia Olympian bodybuilder back in the
day and now she's like in her fifties and she looks like a monster.
Really looks like a monster.
Just faces all.
She looks.
It's like,
when I say monster,
I don't mean like the worst monster.
I mean like a.
wouldn't it be kind of scary?
It's just what she's,
what she did was turn herself into a semi male semi female thing.
Like she changed.
Her appearance has changed and it's become,
you know,
she'd become more male than you're supposed to be or then she was,
you know it.
Yeah.
So you know,
you can't go back either.
I don't think you can.
I think that could probably,
like I saw a Gal,
her chin shaved down,
she was some big bodybuilder lady power lifter Marshall trying to get something
like that Chin shaved down because her chin got too big.
Trying to get all that,
try to use to have that square face.
She changed,
she became much more feminine when they start opening your skin,
grinding down your bones.
Arnold had that done to.
Arnold had developed a very large um,
upper brow area.
Then like there's like before and after liquid,
you look at him and Conan and you look at them skull shaving shaved the skull
down to something more reasonable.
Have you ever just a room though?
That's one of those rumors like the Richard Gere durable and we can never really
know.
We,
me and my buddy literally just talked about this,
those,
those urban myths like that was actually a,
the journal up the ass was a specific Philadelphia News.
They used to say it about in affiliate.
That story,
that urban legend and we and the,
and the other one was uh,
you know,
pumping a gallon,
a comment or.
But you wouldn't be,
you think,
you know,
the origin,
like where it started from that.
That's the literal we were talking about earlier.
Was that a like,
it's amazing how that got around so many years before the Internet.
Like for Shit,
for rumors to happen now is simple one person of any kind of like,
you know,
who has any kind of ear or already kind of voice for people you know,
like says something.
It becomes Gospel to some people.
Yeah,
we've talked about it a bunch of times that that's the mother of all rumors like
that.
No other rumor can close because Eddie Bravo grew up in la.
I grew up in Boston.
We both heard about it at the same time.
Yeah.
You lived in Columbus so it made its way across.
But the Rod Stewart one was nothing compared to roster one was he had his
stomach pumped.
Why don't you just throw up.
Didn't make any sense.
I had thrown up and went,
this is ridiculous.
How much did he drink?
Come on.
That's ridiculous.
Just puke.
But you have to go to the computer to possibly been.
Are you going to go to the top hospital and tell him he drank calm.
Why they going to test it?
How the fuck do they know what it is?
You have to tell him it's fucking milk or glue or something.
But so much that has to come out.
It was blowing,
blowing Peter North.
Imagine going into the hospital and just first of all I thought about how much I
came at the time I was a young,
young boy.
I was probably like 12 when that rumor came out and I was thinking about how
much I can come.
I'm like,
how much more could a grown adult possibly come?
It doesn't even make any sense.
Like how much could it be in my body?
It gives your baby bird come like that's how much come on Carolyn.
I'm taking that back.
You know nothing to think about it.
I think this came out when I was 12 so I probably had never come yet.
Just that weird little shiver.
I probably,
yeah,
I probably really didn't even know like what the actual volume would be.
So that doesn't make any sense,
but I just didn't like they said it was like courts or gallons or something like
that.
12 you knew would come was you just knew it wasn't happening to you when you
can't really find it back then either.
When did pretty woman come out?
Because it came out,
that was way later.
That was way later.
They're going to come out after that.
That's why we all knew who Richard greer gear was.
He knew who he was before the officer.
Gentleman off.
Yeah,
American Gigolo.
He was in a lot of big movies.
Do it seemed like it came out of her.
I'm pretty limited,
but what's to say?
I just came up again because that was the next big,
big,
big hit he did.
It's just amazing that it made it all the way across the country like that.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
The word was that he had left scientology,
scientology.
Where did I get this word?
Have No,
it is the most poorly researched,
whatever,
but this is what I heard is that he left scientology and someone in scientology
said,
well,
yeah,
we'll fix that fucker.
And they put out some crazy rumor that homeboy had a job up his ass.
I believe that we've been following that whole hbo show going.
Yeah.
There's only the one documentary right now.
They're making a documentary about that guy that made the movie.
Scientology is.
They're also making a documentary about Louis Thorough Louis Theroux that
documentary and I love him.
He's doing a special on scientology,
so scientology decided to do a documentary on him
unless it was really good and you're like,
Jeez,
thanks a lot.
Scientology.
Maybe you guys are pretty cool.
That's a cool documentary.
I don't think it's going to be really well.
Well done in it.
Everything's great.
Yeah.
It's all about roses and I think it's a headpiece,
you know?
I think that's what they're doing.
They're trying to intimidate people from bringing attention to them.
You know what I just watched this morning,
I woke up on Netflix and I was watching a documentary called tricked about the
sec guys,
pimp girls.
I get girls like young girls
and pimp them out and the stuff they say to convince them and the girls giving
their account of what,
you know,
what the guy said to them and how they were like,
to hey,
I've got invited to a party and then there was no other party.
He goes,
well,
let's go have some dinner,
and then like,
you know,
two hours later it was like,
fuck this guy's Dick in a car.
It's the same when you hear these adults who were out of scientology talking
about and one thing I was actually laughing a lot in the document is saying
like,
I know it sounds so stupid telling it to you that they were like,
you know,
if you don't sit in this room for the next three months,
you know you're all going to hell and you're,
your inner aliens are going to fuck you up or something.
The tetons,
they came up with it.
You just get like,
I don't know how someone could talk you into that stupid shit.
Like I really don't.
The pimp mentality.
I just,
I guess I'm not that a convincing of a speaker to even think that I could do
some shit like that.
I think you're not a loser and I think there's a lot of people out there and not
saying that everyone who's a prostitute or a scientologist is a loser,
but let's be honest,
not so much in your favor,
but the point being,
it's like if you're down and out and everybody's been down and out,
there's certain people that get a different level of down now than you've ever
been or I or you.
That's the reality of it.
It's not necessarily that it's their fault,
it's just there's levels of down and out and some people,
your life is shit from the moment you're born,
you're born into a terrible environment.
Your parents are fucked up.
Your family life is fucked up.
There's all sorts of abuse.
There's sexual abuse,
there's violence,
there's chaos,
there's crime,
there's starvation.
You never know where your food's coming from and then all of a sudden some dude
comes along and he's given you love and that is reality and it's not pretty and
people don't like it,
but there's levels.
There's levels of fucked up.
You're talking about.
I'm talking about all of it.
Scientology and prostitution and moonies and you know the fill in the blank.
Mormon.
Well that's the one thing.
Extreme recruits seem like if you,
if you get away from you just religion,
like white supremacists and recruit that way.
The downtrodden.
I mean those documentaries.
Hbo used to be my favorite pimps up hoes down.
No.
Skinheads USA.
Do you ever see that one?
That's the one where the guy like,
you know their leader,
he's like and you know,
I leave them alone here.
I trust them during the day when I go work at the tire shop.
You know what I mean?
You worked on like a used tire farm or something?
She would
happen yesterday in Texas.
No,
they had a drama Hammad contest or draw Mohammed art exhibit.
So some guys came and started shooting at them and they,
they killed these two guys that were shooting at this drama.
Hammad exhibit.
Wow.
Yeah.
Shooting at people in Texas is like,
I mean,
seriously.
That's like jumping in the water and try to bite a shark.
It might be one of the dumbest fucking thing around everyone in Texas is armed
to the tits.
You can't just be shooting people in Texas,
especially at a draw Mohammed exhibit,
they should just have draw Mohammed exhibits and then just like guys
with police surround it and just wait for somebody to come and it's like a
honeypot,
you know?
That's like a,
a trap
that is a good way to shoot like really radical extremists.
But did they think that they can shoot you?
Because I see this argued on twitter all the fucking time.
They should've been provoking them.
If all they have to do to provoke you is draw a picture of a guy.
What?
What the fuck?
Like how could anybody beyond there.
So how could anybody ever formed that argument by saying,
oh well maybe they shouldn't be parochial.
They knew what they were doing.
They're doing that to incite violence.
No,
there are drawing.
That's it.
That's all it is.
There's something designed to piss off there.
I just don't think of it.
You don't to get to the point where they want to kill you.
Just not nothing,
nothing.
Your mother could be sucking a gorilla's Dick.
It's not good enough.
You know,
you,
your mothers should be jerking off King Kong or Godzilla fucks her mouth well
enough.
You could draw that.
No one's going to want to kill you.
But I believe in the thing.
It's like,
yeah,
draw.
Mohammed,
who cares?
I think you shouldn't be shown it.
We,
we've already been over the shock that people will murder for this.
So it's Kinda like when,
when that happens,
know it doesn't blow you away as much.
I mean if you hear about cops,
you know,
being in things where they killed a black kid,
are you blown away anymore?
We're desensitized to that story almost at this point.
Yeah,
I.
Well I guess we are to a certain extent,
you know,
there's definitely,
we're not as surprised.
It's still outrageous to people,
but we're not as surprised,
you know,
just the idea that it's somehow or another excusable in any way,
shape or form that you would think about that you think about.
Yeah,
what they did is definitely ridiculous.
If you don't want violence,
it's definitely ridiculous.
But if that's all it takes to incite violence,
how the fuck do you in that cycle,
you just kind of keep perpetuating that to the end of time.
Is it perfect?
It never needs any evolution.
You telling the,
the idea at all that somehow or another it's offensive to draw someone is so
fucking ridiculous in 2015 that anybody that defends in any way,
shape or form even like peripherally you're,
you're way off from.
You've talked to Dave attell,
he'll tell you that the whole world is like more nervous than ever.
You know what I mean?
Like people are more offended than ever.
They are.
They are more offended than ever.
It's a weird time for comedy.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of shit that you're not supposed to make you.
Like people are actually saying.
I.
Someone made a joke about Bruce Jenner and people were saying,
you know,
hey man,
it's not cool to make fun of them.
Oh,
it's not the Jamie Foxx.
And was so like benign.
It was so benign.
And then Bill Maher had one too and everybody was upset at it.
Listen,
you,
you know,
whatever's wrong with him,
whatever's wrong with Bruce Jenner to say that you can't make fun of that.
Like,
well then everything funny is off base,
but you got a guy who was an Olympic gold medalist and now become a woman and he
still wants to be a he,
so he still wants you to refer to them as Bruce until he decides to change that
he's shooting his lips,
he's taking hormones that there's no humor in that.
Really,
really?
That's perfect.
And by the way,
beautiful and peaceful.
Technically it's not too soon either because he's been wearing panty since like
[inaudible] 85 or something.
He said.
So He's been taking hormones for two years,
but he's,
he took hormones back in the late eighties also.
He's done a interview.
He says that this is the second time he's ever done that.
So.
Oh,
so he took,
he started playing the intellect trolls.
Just take off all the hair on his face when he was way younger too.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So he went through all this stuff like way,
way,
way younger.
So yeah.
So it's not even like,
this is things that,
I mean people were making jokes about him without confirmation from him for
years.
Even when that Kardashians show,
when you're making the same exact show that people are actually getting,
like,
like look at this prophecy when you know,
I don't just to throw a name out there.
It was like,
you know,
like Dave Chappelle made a joke three years ago about this.
Like,
yeah,
he's looked like a woman for the past 10 years.
If someone made a joke about it,
there was a joke on siren or something.
The nineties.
Yeah.
Yeah,
about like a thing.
It was a woman from behind and it's Bruce Jenner with the opposite thinking.
It was Bruce Jenner and it's a woman.
One of those.
You didn't watch the,
uh,
interview at all.
I watch very little of it.
There were some really some really great parts in point.
I can't remember it now.
She tear up.
Oh,
this is the.
No,
I didn't hear it.
I thought it was.
The whole thing was ridiculous and hilarious.
You're not supposed to make fun of it,
right?
Because you're supposed to be open minded and you're supposed to be supportive
and kind to someone who's obviously transitioned through a very,
very rough and difficult thing that's all well and good and I'm with that.
I get that.
But if you're not homophobic or transphobic running that and you really don't
have any problem with anybody doing anything,
they want to do whatever you want to.
I'll totally accepted.
I have zero problem with it at all,
but to tell me it's not funny.
Please get the fuck Outta here.
You got a guy who's becoming a like.
There's a guy who's six foot six who's playing college,
women's basketball.
He's 50.
Okay.
He was a man most of his life.
Had Children.
Just decided at one point in time that he wanted to be a woman and then found
out that because he's now a new sex,
he can reenter college sports.
So he played college basketball as a fucking man back in the day and now he's
playing college basketball as a girl,
but he's 50 and he's and he's a giant full exchange,
full sex change.
So he's moving around with and then there's people that are freaking out about
it and there's people that are saying you shouldn't make fun of it and you
should just let it be like look to to say this is not controversial is crazy.
You're a crazy person to say there's not some controversy in a six foot 6:50
year old man playing college sports with girls.
I mean what?
Okay,
now he's a woman so we have to call them a woman now.
Okay.
But can we just can see that he was a man for 40 fucking years and has a Benz
frame and is enormous.
Like can we can see that being 50 is probably a little old to be playing
basketball against teenagers?
No,
because you've got to protect people's feelings.
We write letters and shit.
Yeah.
I mean look at the whole thing is like her.
Excuse me,
but he went to Bruce Jenner thing.
Where I found so interesting is,
is that I feel like
by what people would say,
I'd be judged in my life as like phobic,
whatever that word means.
Yet I have no pr.
I think you should be able to,
whatever you want to do,
if you want to cut your dick off to get a pussy made by Dr. get your Dick cut
off.
But I don't think I should be judged because I think that's bonkers.
You know what I mean?
Like if you want to do it,
do it.
I don't care.
I'm not afraid of it.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't not shake somebody's hand because they were transgender in any of
that.
Okay.
But it's like,
I still think it's like a fucking.
I think it's a decision that you probably should have been talked out of by
somebody.
So maybe and maybe not.
See.
I'm not talking about you dressing like a woman or being gay or feeling this
thing,
but
I've made an argument many times and I've got into many arguments about this
because people just jumped the gun on the words.
But with gay I'm a,
you know,
my friend with me as gay here,
I've tons of gay friends.
I have no weirdness with gay people at all,
but I think it's like a deviate.
It's like something that went wrong almost like,
you know,
to the extent of like webbed fingers or something,
but there shouldn't be anything wrong with it and people should.
We have to do whatever they want to do,
who gives a shit,
you know what I'm saying at all.
But to start,
if you're gonna start monitoring your body to do something where it's like,
even when it's done,
like no one's,
no one's really happy from the stuff I've read it.
Read and watched elise with their new pussy.
I don't know.
You could say that you have to
say.
Right?
I
said the stuff that I've seen and read two things.
One,
the,
the idea that they're all the same,
like there's levels of,
of everything you know,
and there's certain people that want to be transgender and they still want to
keep the,
you know,
which is fine too.
I think there's some people that have mental illness and there's some people
that really do feel like they were born in the wrong body.
I agree with you.
There's nothing that.
Why would I?
I think because I think it's like a misfire though,
but this is what I think is very rare that you can cure something mental with
surgery.
It's very rare that there's something that doesn't feel right to you,
which I guess is a mental thing or the,
you know,
how you view yourself and you could fix that with surgery.
That gets real strange.
Like as far as like just accepting who you are and what you are and what,
what nature is a term.
I would never want to be the person to tell someone what to do.
Like you and I,
we both covered in tattoos.
You know what?
If someone came along and tell us we couldn't do it.
I love tattoos.
I think they look bad ass now,
Joe.
Yeah,
I heard I heard,
but it's like I don't give a fuck man,
do whatever you want to do.
I don't have any problem with it but I don't know what.
I don't know what you're feeling.
So for me to even comment on it in any way is kinda kind of ridiculous for me to
assume like I know what's going on,
whether you're,
I know you're crazy or whether I know that you were actually really born a woman
or whether you know,
fill in the blank,
a variety of reasons to decide you're in the wrong gender.
You get might get bored.
Being a dude,
you might have a bunch of women around you that you like more than you like men
and you wish you were one of them.
I know a dude who
for the longest time was telling my wife he's gay.
No,
he's okay.
He's okay.
Boom.
He comes out.
He's like 46.
This poor bastard like wasted his whole fucking life pretending that he wasn't
gay and like,
this dude is gay.
I'm telling you he's gay.
But he was always around these women.
He would hang around them and talk with them and be one of them.
It's like you were,
there was the energy in the room.
Like there's an energy in the room if there's a dude and like maybe his
girlfriend or a bunch of their friends,
there's an energy like,
well there's guys here and he's not going to talk like us,
but this dude was in the mix.
He was in the mix with them about everything.
Have you seen the new bag,
like you would do that hand stuff that girls do you know,
he would.
He would move like them man.
And if you had gotten a hold of that dude and talked him into it,
he probably would have become a woman.
Really.
I could.
I think he could have been hypnotized him made him become a woman,
but gay man.
See,
that's a weird one.
I think first of all,
definitely born that way.
Definitely.
I agree.
I don't necessarily think it's like A.
I don't think it's a bad thing.
They seem to be enjoying it.
I think the only way it would be bad is if there wasn't enough people to
reproduce.
I think it's just a deviation.
I think it's a deviation.
Like some people are tall,
but the exact thing is Dva,
but I don't think it's A.
I don't think it's a negative,
you know,
it just doesn't seem to be negative.
The only thing that would be negative is that they don't have a.
correct.
Hold on.
Fuck.
There's,
there's this transgender Webcam room that on chatter bait where you can look at
transgenders doing webcam stuff.
You just stumbled upon this and I know.
No,
I was with this girl that she's like,
you gotta check this out.
And I'm like,
I don't want to look at this.
She's like,
I want to see a good fake vagina.
And there was this one guy that was looked like on the top look,
just like Thompson girl,
like a normal guy and on the bottom he had a really well done vagina and it was
deep.
It was deep.
She was jealous because he had like this humongous vibrator in him and I didn't
know some.
You are haunting.
I didn't know it was deep though.
That's such a weird throughout.
I've a world right now with that image of the girl with a giant deep push.
Robert Dawn,
I thought that like the fake vagina.
It wasn't a deep thing I thought was just like kind of like outer,
you know,
you just split a Dick Open.
I always assume it was as deep as long as your dick was almost like it was as
simple as just pushing the dickhead like all the way back.
And they do like real surgery now.
If I remember,
I think they can actually construct a tube in there.
I'm sure it's advanced,
but you know,
I've interviewed,
he was creamy,
he was creamy like.
So what's that cream is that code has to be like some lube that.
I mean it has to.
How much did you watch spirit?
Do you know that movie x mocking other words?
They weren't really robots,
right?
There's always.
I've seen fake
ges before for sure.
I've seen some fake dongs torn.
This is one guy.
Every,
every porn he does,
he keeps his pants on and his fake Dong just comes through the hole.
They make them like ridiculously strap.
It was a fake.
I'm like,
who wants to see this grove?
Fucking this guy who's a liar.
I've got a big rubber fake.
I
interviewed twice now the uh,
the transgender chick that dated Michael Phelps was born like both sexes.
Oh,
right.
And then,
uh,
and became a woman.
She had a lot of surgery but uh,
but it's not transgendered than just,
she just,
she just did a porno porno and she told me to look at the trailer.
I watched the trailer and it's,
it's,
it's odd looking over jumping.
She has a girl's body,
but it is this available online vagina.
You watch it right now.
Okay.
Pull it up Jimmy.
As long as it doesn't get on the USTREAM,
we don't want to get in trouble and it's called going for the gold.
But if she.
Well let me ask you this because it's so important.
If she,
if she was born with both with.
Okay.
Let me ask you,
if you were born with both,
would you make a decision?
I think in this day and age you,
you'd better,
you'd be better off being that one dude that can do it all.
I mean good light.
Yeah,
I mean,
unless you're home with him,
he bit decision.
Like I think crazy young,
I think it's like a baby parents.
Sometimes
parents will your Dick awakened gas pump into your
parents would have way too much power to decide which direction a kid would go.
In that sense.
People argue that the same thing with circumcision.
Well,
circumcision circumcise and their dick got cut off so they transitioned them to
girls.
Do you know that?
Yeah,
they,
they lost their dick and like intersex surgery.
Mistake.
What am I going to see your face like?
Am I going to get the seed in this [inaudible] this is the.
They're going to show the box.
Well she looks a lot like a Gal.
Oh,
so they have a swimmer?
Come and meet her through the pool.
Bam.
How road.
Whoa.
What's that?
Her whole hand is to say if he's got a gay man having sex with what he's eating.
It is.
Okay.
So is that guy what's going on?
What's going on?
What is that?
How do you.
What is that exactly?
Like regular sex?
Yeah.
This totally looks like a man having sex with a girl that looks like a total
vagina.
Like if you didn't enjoy that vagina,
you're just picky.
Oh wait,
I thought this was their hermaphrodite.
Okay,
well we just saw jerk off on a former male,
a former male to male female trans.
The box there,
they showed it.
I didn't see it close up.
It looks like that.
It's like a box with balls.
It's a large stitches area.
Above the box.
Whole area lifts or a far left disturbing.
It looks like there's balls inside the lips,
but again,
like if you're trapped on a desert island and you get,
you get mad at this,
you're a picky fuck.
I trapped in a hotel lobby to give it.
I'll give it a whirl.
Being we're,
we're all,
you know,
we're living in a weird world where there's
gonna come a time I think if not in our lives and our grandchildren's lives for
sure where they're gonna be able to change your sex.
Like you're going to be able to simply,
yeah,
they're just going to give you some sort of a genetic alteration.
You'll be a woman.
I don't think that's going to be outside the realm of possibility within the
next hundred 50,
200 years.
They're just so they're so close to fixing so many different things about people
and then once they fix everything,
I mean they're never gonna fix everything.
We're always going to have some diseases and colds and flus and shit,
but I think they're going to be able to do some pretty incredible shit to your
body and then they going to get to a point where people start going,
you know what,
there's a clinic in Thailand and all you have to do is pay them $50,000 and you
know,
you can become a woman,
like a real woman and you can turn back if you don't like it.
And they'll show clients that every six years they go back.
You know,
I was a man for five years.
I went,
I enjoyed a lot of lovely things that when I was a girl that you appreciate it
more and then it's balanced.
My perspective being a man for 30 years and a woman for five than a mannequin,
I just kind of get it.
For years I just took off left and right.
Maybe not.
Maybe just if you could yoga,
just live as a girl.
That's it.
Just do girl shit.
Also,
the other thing you're going to have to deal with,
it's like you see the perfect gal.
You know,
you see the fruit,
perfect Gal walking down the street like just big ass and thin waist big Jesus
Christ.
Your jeans just call out,
right?
Like your DNA just goes,
oh my God.
Like when,
if a group of guys were like this,
we're not rude,
right?
We're not rude people.
But if we saw some gal and she was outside of Ir Range,
like she was walking down the street,
you know,
you would probably be like,
dude,
look at this.
And you go,
oh my God.
Nature is amazing and interesting to look at the poll.
We're all like,
this is like a sunset or a fantastic art exhibit.
You know,
you're watching like nature's art.
Walk down the street in the shape of a beautiful girl.
Well,
what if you could just get that?
Maybe use he just go to a doctor and then your body straightens up and get
straighter.
You know,
if you're a big boxy type Gal,
your body to roll it slips down the ways your ass pop south flunk your tits pump
and then everybody looks hot as fuck.
It's not like sexual communism to some degree.
You kind of want to keep it like
sexual confidence.
You really do want to keep because don't you want to keep the elite?
Because there is something.
What I find interesting about working about looking at like a,
like chicks in that capacity at all.
Is that like a,
there's some that are just fucking undeniable.
Do you know what I mean?
Girls who I thought were beautiful.
My buddies like last night was like,
that's an La six and I'm like,
I thought she was stunning.
How about beyonce?
If you don't think she's hot,
you're gay,
you have to be gay.
If you don't look at beyond saying,
go Jesus Christ that what's that fucking song?
If you like it,
then you should've put a ring on it.
Very sexy for sure.
Oh yeah.
Look at that.
There's a lot of girls that are undeniable that it's like they're attractive and
pretty bummed about the undeniable where everyone's like and
her Prime Jennifer Lopez liable,
but just go ahead and stuff.
Fuck Salma Hayek and her problem is just fucking Stein undeniable.
Kate Upton for a couple of years.
Undeniable.
That's it is absolutely true.
But there's some people that no one could even argue like,
oh,
their asses too flat or it's too big or it's too,
you know,
if you,
what's amazing to me,
like you,
Nicki Minaj looks,
you know,
some people think that's ideal.
It's people like it's retarded looking,
you know,
it's like,
it's ridiculous.
Well the problem with that is did she always looked like that?
And if she didn't always look like that,
how's her house that big?
Am I looking at bags of water?
Like what am I looking?
I just saw her on a,
on snl because I've seen her wear her ass looks big fat and like good and like
the porn.
So I guess kind of wig.
When I saw it last time,
she literally looks like a,
like a battle droid,
just like some kind of like what?
Just like tank bottoms,
you know what I mean?
It's like we're in like the nineties.
We never thought that was hot.
We were like looking at girls fucking fat ass dude.
I was just going to bring that.
Not that it was a fast but it wasn't something that everybody aspires to.
Like I was driving down the street the other day and there was like some ad
about building a better,
but you know,
like they're having classes at the gym just to build better butts.
I think it's like a two and we're for real.
It's built by solid but with out here and then you see all these girls squatting
and the back and like,
oh Jesus Christ.
Like what happened?
What happened?
Well that's a major shift.
You know what it was black male culture kinda dictated a the fashion and style
and stuff for white dudes for a long time.
Kind of taking over the style of that.
And now like finally,
like the black women are now kind of setting the tone for like the body shape.
I think it was the depression.
I think people were so poor and starving.
They forgot they liked big assets and then it took a while before they woke up
and then got through the fifties and sixties and seventies and eighties.
And then sir mix a lot.
Came along and he had that one song and everybody was like,
yeah,
wait a minute,
why don't,
why is it so great to me?
And then you,
you too,
what the fuck?
How can we be ignoring this?
And it's almost like somewhere in there there's a good research and now it's
everyone.
You talk to men like what's the most important thing,
you know?
Uh,
what's the most attractive thing to a girl?
Almost every guy says ass.
Almost every guy is the cola wars cola.
Warren.
I'm a face guy of course.
And you'd face is important phase.
We'll do a lot also as a guy who couldn't be picky when I was younger,
I was a fat dude,
like face meant a lot,
you know what I mean?
If I could go with a pretty face,
I can look at it and if she was big like,
you know,
maybe she'll say yes,
maybe she'll go back with me.
It really sucks too when you get close to a girl and then you notice like the
sunlight shines on her face and like,
oh shit,
she's got whiskers or oh she has no chin at all.
She was like,
no,
I'm just saying that's how important faces because like if it was tits or ass
and tits had this humongous brown mole on it,
you'd be like,
it's weird for me to.
If someone said like tits or ass,
like I over both of those,
I'd rather see any girl's pussy.
I don't know why that means the world to me.
You're a pervert.
That's my gas.
It's not even knowing that even if it's just like,
even when she was like,
you know,
hair like it just a,
hey,
I want to see the pubes just a little bit just to the mountain,
the pubic pubic bone,
the hump.
When I remember being a teenager,
what bummed me out when girls all started shaving their heads bald was some girl
told me.
She goes,
I go,
let me see your pubes.
And she goes,
he goes,
I shaved my pussy bald.
I go,
really?
And then she pulled her pants down,
click the top of her class.
If you call it pussy slit I guess.
And Gosh,
what a good kid.
It's amazing though,
how not exciting it was to see that if there was pussy here,
there you'd be like,
Oh,
I'm not supposed to see that.
But when there's nothing there,
know what I mean?
It takes away like a.
and maybe it's maybe you know,
I'm 37 is when I was a kid,
like all porn.
Everything was like pussy hair and if you,
if you were.
So maybe that's what I'm just drawn to in that way,
but I find it very like,
uh,
it,
it really takes away.
I mean,
when a girl wears those bikinis where it just comes like right above where their
pussy starts,
like you don't feel like you're seeing anything that weird.
But if,
but if you saw a girl laying down and some pubes are coming out the side of her
bathing suit,
that's actually,
you feel like you're seeing more than if you saw all the top of her posts it
album.
What's that?
Black curly hair or America does a great album cover.
Pull that up.
Hustler.
I think that's a great album.
Cover black crows or the shit that big muff.
I,
uh,
yeah.
It's weird when you.
I kind of forgot about pussy hair and then when you see it you're like,
you kind of miss it.
I missed it.
Weird because when were kids it was like kind of iconic.
It was like that represented like,
like they would call it guys,
we'll call it a beaver,
you know,
just a little bit of pubes Pocono number.
Samantha,
remember Samantha Fox in the eighties and then they found out that like over in
England she did a bunch of like naked naked pictures and like,
yeah,
big Bush.
She was a page six girl,
like they had that.
They used to have page six of their newspaper where they would show tits.
That's why they were so much more advanced than us with their art.
That's why the Beatles and shit came from.
There was so much more relaxed.
They would chug debts in the newspaper.
Relax.
It's just tense.
Everybody's so freaked out.
And Harris was more of like an eyelash for the vagina for periods and stuff.
So when it get everywhere and that's why girls are,
that's not what it is.
The uh,
the butthole hair was always disturbing though.
Yeah.
I don't like nobody ever liked the buddle here because some girls just did not
know what they're doing when Kim to wiping.
And back then nobody had a bad day and nobody had baby wipes.
It was toilet paper.
Sometimes some of it stuck around
for a little gig
super tightly rolled up.
Did you know those little shit joint?
Could you know those little notes,
trimmers that you buy you,
you use that for your asshole also?
You
can't.
Yeah,
I was unaware of the.
Well,
it's not rocket science.
It's not like trying to figure out solar power,
nose hair trimmers on your eyes.
It's just if it cuts hair cuts,
hair,
it just does.
And it doesn't cut you and stuff.
Well,
couldn't you get like one of those face shavers was little nice ones down there
with your ass.
So you have a shaving your hair.
Oh,
I just leave my girls.
You know what though?
You could do a way better job of cleaning it if your asshole is shaved,
but your asshole will grow that hair back like wild Bush.
And then in a couple of days you'll be just squeezing your ass cheeks everywhere
he go to keep from just digging in there and crushing.
Just clawing at your asshole like a wolf trying to bury a Caribou.
Fucking that stubble ball stuff.
How come my face stubble barely bothers me.
My head stubble stubble up here right now.
No,
it doesn't bother me at all.
But Jesus Christ,
my asshole.
Just
moving around and your chair when you wipe your ass and he grabbed like a bundle
of hair on the way out.
You know what's the best man?
One Wipe Charlie's.
You ever tried that?
I want them so bad.
It's like a dude wipe.
Like that kind of a thing.
He was a baby wipe.
They made.
They made for men,
but they don't smell like flowers.
Like you just got ass fucked by a flower forest.
Yeah.
Well I.
That Japanese thing is the shit man.
Yeah.
Install one in here.
I'm going to install it in here.
Eventually.
Just kind of does it shoot like high pressure water.
The shit hanging out for an hour?
Yeah.
High pressure.
Wind pressure.
Water.
Warm Air.
It drives your asshole off.
There's two different speeds to the water shoots in your asshole totos.
It also cleans your vagina.
If you're a gal who cleans your vagina,
you can back your badge up,
get a little tingly,
tingly,
and if you know little time and the.
You went to joe and said,
Gal,
we went to Japan.
I just sat there for a half hour with the one shooting in my asshole because it
just felt so good because it hit like the back wall butthole that long.
I'd have to do it to feel like I was like getting.
I'm still going to have to do paper afterwards.
No,
no.
You didn't walk out with worried.
It was so clean.
It was like taking a shower for your butthole.
Pretty meticulous.
It's not doing as good a job.
I'm telling you.
You just smearing.
Even if you use baby wipes,
you just smearing over your hair.
Okay.
Imagine if I took some shit and I just rubbed into the top of your head.
You're like,
I'm good.
I got a baby wipe,
but if I had never accept that,
if I get in the shower and you would clean your asshole here,
fair enough.
But if he.
You told me I had 70 baby wipes and a roll of toilet paper.
I'd take a shower.
Jesus Christ,
this fork and shit all day too.
Don't worry about it.
I rubbed it with 70 baby wipes.
I be like,
oh,
that's not enough.
You've got to watch this fucking thing.
You've got to get it in the washing machine.
I didn't these hot water and Sun,
but again,
let's say baby wipes and vapor,
just trying to get my method approved.
It's still shit.
You'd pick shower after the shower,
but I also before and fairness.
Yeah.
I mean I don't do anything.
I don't go out for the day though until I shower after I stand up or to wipe or
sit down,
stand up,
sitting on even a possibility.
Fuck wipes or asked.
Sitting down.
You must have really shitty cuffs.
I know.
What are your cuffs?
I don't do it.
He does.
I wanted you to do a second minute.
I stand up.
Find a target.
Not going to stand up.
Stand up.
I know there's people.
Most people sit in
their sleeves.
Smeller watch.
Guaranteed
is that.
One of my buddies told me,
he goes from the front,
reaching between his
smell,
his balls.
I can.
You don't.
He's going to have.
Damn.
It is a very specific protocol.
I imagine when people smelled like when they hadn't figured out wiping and then
someone finally figured out how to just kind of clean the area off a little bit
and everybody's like,
Oh yeah,
why don't we.
Why don't you just be covered with shit all the time.
When they used to do this poll on when it had red band.com,
I did this point and I did.
Who stands up?
Who sits down and it was almost 50 slash 50,
don't have red band dot Com forwards now.
Oh,
but yeah,
it was 50 slash 50 like I know all these.
It's like the dress,
the stupid dress take into accounts.
Fifty percent of the people that were going to your website.
It's a small savages is weird.
Yeah,
it's very weird.
You're not going to do a good job already.
Sits in wipes and you can see it in Juke lamb because he was right.
It's documented.
Well.
He should have.
If ever there was a fair where there was a like a billboard for stand up and
wipe your ass just
because something's wrong with it.
Especially that one.
That video is so ridiculous.
Already had like a homer Simpson's mouth asshole.
I watched it the other day.
It's still in lively.
The uncensored.
Everyone in Washta.
Well,
we had a,
we had a whole episode of my podcast Legion scanning,
so I do it.
And he came in and one of our buddies said that,
uh,
one of,
one of our buddies that he had a hemorrhoid and he showed everyone is asshole
already said,
uh Oh.
He said that he was like,
do hold his asshole against lew Lewis.
And I mean that's what blew everyone.
I mean it was like uncommon.
I told them that I was worried about how something's wrong.
I'm months threat.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's going away,
man.
That's red is going to have flare ups like that.
He's still alive.
He never killed.
Did you claim so really?
And he still has the skittle balls.
Like I swear to God if someone was going to but fuck already,
I feel like you could pull Ari's asshole up there.
Dick.
Like a sock.
Well he's in.
He's in Thailand right now.
He's probably getting his asshole
brody Stevens special police.
Oh my God,
that's ridiculous.
why?
What's wrong with that poor boy?
Cause he put,
wiping dry,
wiping,
I guess.
Aggressive driveway.
I mean I couldn't picture what else would make that happen.
We were all asked doctors.
All of a sudden I remember I reminded him Procta,
remember that night that happened?
I sent A.
I sent Duncan trussell a screenshot and then he calls me back and what the hell
is he got?
He got pink sock.
I didn't even know what a pink sock was,
but that's what it looked like.
He got turned out.
Yeah,
he's got a prolapse prolapse.
Good.
Oh God.
Jesus Christ.
Skittle balls.
I can't believe we were at the comedy and Magic Club and we're like,
all right.
All right.
Show us your butthole.
All right,
now show us your boss and his boss had all those little balls in it.
There's little tiny skittles.
No,
that was at the comedy magic club
already do stunts.
Like a fucking autistic kid shows your button at the end of the,
at the end of the Juke clam.
It's like six months later and you go,
let's take a look back,
or let's see what is,
but what it looks like now,
and we're in the comedy and magic club and then with or no,
this was weird.
Penny had skittles attached to his boss.
His boss were really like,
like they,
they looked like they had egg sacks and them or something like tons of little
malls wrong with them.
Yeah.
But again,
it ends with you going,
what the fuck's wrong with your balls?
I blocked that out like a child molestation
comics that we liked to show each other our Cox and show each other assholes.
I've seen when it comes to like my friend's Dicks,
I've seen so many of my friends,
dicks like Chili de is used to pull his dick out all the time and it would be
hilarious.
You know,
Dunkin's pulled his dick out.
I've never seen dog Duncan that voice.
It's because you want to cross all the lines that you can,
that you can cross bike possibly,
right?
Like you could.
I mean like I've got some weird ones,
red balls out for like almost an entire episode of Opie and Anthony.
We gave this gal stocker patty.
We gave her a fake breast trip,
was just a regular listerine breath strip and we told her that it was a
psychedelic drug and she took it.
We told that she's tripping their balls off and so she,
she's there and he pulls the sack out and we pretend like we don't notice it.
And she's like,
oh my God,
his balls around.
What are we,
what are you talking about?
Slow for this whole episode.
We're pretending that red bar and she is talking about how bad she's tripping
about.
Oh,
she can't believe.
Like it was complete power of suggestion and placebo effect.
Like she was tripping her balls off.
Did you ever show your Dick and balls?
Does anyone at the store early,
early days?
I don't know.
Bobby Lee's another one.
I've seen many pictures of bobby tucked like a woman every day.
His pants in the bar area of the comedy store.
I've only,
I've only met bobby like four or five times and I've seen his dick and I asked a
couple times.
I think Jamie only shows me as Joe.
He's just always Kinda Tago not.
I don't know guys with real big pieces.
We'll pull them out pretty quick too.
That's not true because I've never done it.
I was going with the fact that I've never done it.
I definitely can't say I haven't shown someone.
My Dick.
Kevin pulled it out for whatever reason.
I definitely have done it at least once,
but it's not a mainstay.
Like for Joey,
for years it was a mainstay.
Joey would have his pants because you know Joe,
he doesn't really find belts at work.
He doesn't find pants that fit and so he's always an state.
Always.
We can just shake and his pants will drop
his balls and Dick or just hanging out in front of everybody.
Joey did that.
I don't know how many times I got a picture of him carrying a waitress on his
shoulder and his pants are down by his knees and his balls and his dick is
hanging out and he's in the back parking lot area of the comedy store.
And by the way,
this was back when Joey had zero career.
Joey gave no fucks even when he was starving.
Okay.
Joey Diaz has been Joey Diaz since the jump,
like he's always been a madman.
Like before he was killed on the road and making great money.
He didn't give a fuck.
Even back then it was barely getting by trying to hustle,
get gigs together,
but he is always been like,
that's like he's the flag bearer for not giving a fuck on the west coast.
You say you don't give a fuck,
but you joey Diaz not give a fuck.
That was always the flag bearer.
He was always the standard,
isn't it?
Where the girls don't just show their pussies more often,
like they don't just get a check up my pussy just like guys did.
There's a couple of limits it.
But how far that's come is way different.
Like fast,
average girls will pull them pussies out.
It's pretty crazy.
Well,
I think there's a lot of competition now too with all this tinder and all these
different match.com and all these different dating sites and shit.
People are just getting laid left and right.
Like you get left out in the cold if you try to hold back.
I mean that,
that fucking.
What's that?
The website's about Madison.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's websites where it's like two people to cheat to fuck you and imagined
dating a girl that her job was like a secretary to work for Ashley Madison.
Never trusted her.
I trusted nobody.
You couldn't trust her.
No one would trust things are great.
It's hilarious.
I mean,
what a great idea.
Make a website that helps people cheat and what so smaller than their
commercials too.
They have it be a girl getting caught by her husband using Ashley
and then he goes,
she's like,
you know,
I don't want to be celibate anymore.
And he goes,
I understand.
He's like,
she goes,
you know,
maybe you should try it too.
Like you know exactly what you should.
You should both just,
it's probably not how it goes.
It's going to gun's gonna come out,
shots fired,
cops show up.
No one wants to go in the house.
Domestic violence.
Always this scary things for police officers.
And when we think on the computer,
Ashley Madison come
shooting back and forth.
Ashley Madison,
this is what we do.
It's crazy,
man.
Five percent spike from women on the day after mother's Day.
Whoa.
Well that's what they're saying.
According to its data.
Come on.
Forty two percent increase in sign.
That's what we expect.
Come on.
Where's your fucking data bits?
Ashley Madison.
Math.
Different system is a fluff piece.
You know,
this ain't no.
Scientists are doing studies on whether Ashley Madison gonna Experience an
uptake in business.
They did that to make people pay attention to.
I'm not on my.
I've never done tinder.
Really?
You don't need to use sexy bitch will not my girl,
my growing and Dick and tell them jokes.
My girlfriend,
uh,
she's,
she's on thrinder where you try,
but that doesn't work ever.
Will you become friends with.
No,
no,
no.
She's on thrinder where you like.
It's trying to find threesomes,
like fun girl.
Yeah,
but I don't know.
It hasn't worked yet.
I mean we've been a couple of weeks ago.
You need cocaine for that.
Yeah.
That's the only way that we pulled it off
start fires before they figured out lighters.
You're absolutely right.
It wasn't so good sitting there with some fucking moss and a stick.
I guess calc without helps for sure.
Yeah.
That's.
That's if he tried to get her to post strippers,
they're already cooked up.
You don't have to worry about it.
Look at you.
You're thinking ahead.
I love it.
Just go to strip clubs.
I mean,
don't you feel like going with the Strip club once it was her first time and she
did pull a stripper.
She was great.
Some guys feel,
at least that are comics that like the lifestyle,
so ridiculous.
You're in a nightclub every fucking night.
You're drinking all the time.
You're smoking pot.
If anybody's got mushrooms,
you're going to do those to you're.
You're eating at 3:00 in the morning,
you're getting up whenever the fuck you want to.
You're hanging out with hilarious,
ridiculous people that want to get high and go to the movies at one in the
afternoon and you're like,
fuck it,
let's do it,
and you're laughing all the time.
You go down the road,
hanging out and going from airport to rental,
car to hotel,
all the cracking jokes like this.
Very few people that can relate to that kind of DEBACA.
Most people are so tied down to some crazy nine to five corporate life,
job life,
business life.
Well,
you've got to fucking pretend to be somebody for eight hours a day,
can't be loose.
He can't be free and everybody's trying to conform to that in there after work
life too.
Everybody's like this weird fucking father knows best type clone figure
of what a,
an adult and a family is.
And comics were out there living in this weird,
chaotic life.
But I've,
I've,
I've actually very young,
had the really balanced both those worlds and I did,
you know,
it was not the right thing to do.
I guess in many ways,
and it was done poorly,
but when I got right to the point in comedy,
it was about like 23.
I've been doing it for like three,
four years and I was in a world where now I was like going on the road and like
if I was opening for a towel or patrice and getting pussy and stuff like that
and kind of living that lifestyle.
I also was married with a baby doll,
you know what I mean?
Like my daughter is 12 now I'm 30,
so you know what I mean?
So almost 13.
So it's like,
it is weird.
I did it to do both those worlds.
So you know,
I was picking up from school every day and then you know,
two weeks later I'm in Rhode Island with my buddies and there's,
you know,
some fat girls blowing everybody and shared,
you know what I mean?
Just like weird shit.
Like you know what I'm saying?
Like just like it was very weird to straddle those worlds because you also try
to instill morals and class and to somebody while you're just like anything.
And it was,
I mean I did just like sexual stuff,
especially man,
like so much stuff just for like girls.
I wasn't even attracted to anything.
I'm just like,
well she will blow me and you know,
I have an opener with me and she'll suck his dick to and whatever,
you know,
like just insane behavior that most people,
the average guy,
even in the world of like,
you know,
sexual looseness that we're in kind of now with that stuff with all social
media,
like not a ton of guys have had threesomes with.
It's even one of their two buddy's fucking a girl or two girls at once,
let alone some of the shit.
Someone way better looking than me has not.
I've done a lot more stuff.
They don't have the time.
Most people going from college,
whatever sexy you can get in college and then you know,
you're working all the time trying to get your degree.
Then you get a degree,
get a job.
You did get in the job,
you're working overtime,
you're always exhausted.
Like where's the time for threesomes?
Where you fit in your coke time.
You know,
all that stuff.
That's what I was gonna say is I like a lot of comics relate to strippers
because strippers are also live in this crazy sort of de Bockarie filled life as
well.
You know,
they're making way more money than the average girl.
They're dancing on Paul's there,
partying with friends there.
They're totally irresponsible and they're fun to hang around with because they
don't judge you for being a fuck up as much as say a gal who's a lawyer,
you know,
when you're a loser comic and you're,
you're dating a girl who is a lawyer as well.
My daughter's mother's a lawyer.
It is,
it's pretty funny.
Hilarious.
So she went to school.
She did the whole thing.
She did the hard work.
She got her law degree.
She took the bar.
I mean fuck man.
Yeah,
like no shit.
And,
and,
and I tried in years past to Kinda like,
there'd be these flickers where I try to like bring her into the debauchery,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
we should do some of this weird shit together.
And she would.
But I felt like I was corrupting a square to kind of wanting to be.
You know what I mean?
That she's a square.
I don't want to present like that,
but it's just like I felt like I was like,
this is.
You wouldn't be involved in kind of creepy shit
if it wasn't for me.
This isn't where you want to.
I this.
There's nothing wrong with the term square,
but I agree with you.
There's nothing wrong with being a square to.
Right?
No.
Like if that's what you're into.
Like there's a lot of people that just feel like going home,
having tea and reading a book like that is a nice night for them.
They could.
Why not?
If it brings in genuine joy,
why does it?
Why do you have to go to a rave?
You know?
Why?
Why do?
Why do you have to go on thrinder mother lost soul.
Take this dance for lost souls.
Asian lost souls.
I mean every we just do whatever the fuck you want to do.
The more people will get over that.
I think that's one of the things that I really,
truly have hoped for with this new generation of kids.
All these people,
I think growing up,
excuse me,
growing up with the Internet,
I think they're just going to have a totally different acceptance of people
being different.
I just think that we grew up in a weird time,
man.
We grew up.
I mean I'm 10 years older than you,
so I grew up mostly kind of in the early eighties,
you know,
I went to school in [inaudible] 81 was my first year of high school,
so I think that we just grew up in a time where we were just guessing nobody,
nobody kind of knew how many people were out there that were filled with the
same amount of angst.
You kind of guessed by the movies that we all gravitated towards or you guessed
by the songs that we all listen to fucking coffee with butter in it too.
I might have to stop,
might have to go straight black heel back to starbucks.
I'm not going back to starbucks,
caveman coffee all the way.
But uh,
the butter man is not good pre podcast for the phlegm production.
So the point is we didn't know,
man.
Everybody knows.
Now you know,
like if you're like transgender is a perfect example.
We're talking about like people that feel they were.
If you were a fucking kid and you were growing up in 1984 and you were a woman
trapped in a man's body,
you had no fucking friends.
You had no recourse.
Good luck trying to find out other people just like you.
What are you going to join some club somewhere that harbors them where they have
to come out and admit they're part of this.
No Manal you go online,
you could find a whole community of people.
Sure.
For anything,
for anything you say.
But even like,
you know,
there's communities of fucking pedophiles that the final chapter,
which is horrible.
That is horrible man.
And that's,
that's a real,
that's a real issue.
You know,
that was one of those was that fucking piece.
There's a big expo is a piece about this guy and his boyfriend who raised their
son to be like a sex slave.
They were bringing his son to all these other grown men.
I forget.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Jamie?
Have you seen this guy,
you know,
I don't even want to talk about because it's so disturbing.
But it was,
it was a,
it was a crazy expos where they followed these,
uh,
these guys for a while and they suspected it and apparently they had kept this
very close knit relationship with all these rich pedophiles over the world and
they brought their son all around them and he was really young boy and they were
using him as this sex slave and they had figured it out.
Somehow or another,
they figured out how to crack group of tight lipped people.
Eventually someone email slipped out or something and they figured it out and
eventually brought these guys to put this poor kid.
I mean,
what the fuck,
man,
these are the people that love you,
your parents and your being paraded around with them like you're the perfect
family and meanwhile you're bringing this kid around to all these pedophiles and
they're fucking sociopath or psychopath.
I think that's both right.
I mean,
that's a sociopath in that you have no empathy and a psychopath and that you're
doing damage,
right?
Is that what?
So what is the difference between sociopath say that?
Although path can feel emotion final right now,
psychopath does feel motion.
Really.
It's like a flashlight that can do chores
is a horribly fantastic way to put it.
It's like a room but with a butthole.
Okay.
Here's the difference between a psychopath and associate path for.
Let's see.
This society has conspired with Hollywood to seemingly sexy psychological terms,
door collective consciousness,
psychopath and sociopath.
Psychopath and sociopath are pop psychology terms for what psychiatry calls an
antisocial personality disorder.
Today,
these two terms are not really well defined in the psychology research
literature.
Nonetheless,
there are some general differences between the two types of personality types
which will look in this article.
Both types of personalities have pervasive pattern of disregard for the safety
and rights of others.
Deceit and manipulation are central features to both types of personalities and
contrary to popular belief,
a psychopath or sociopath is not necessarily violent.
Okay,
so psychopath and sociopath,
they share a diagnosis.
There's a antisocial personality as someone who has three or more of the
following traits,
regularly breaks were flaunt the law.
Big Jay Oakerson constantly lies and deceives others.
Brian Red Band is impulsive and doesn't plan ahead.
Joe Rogan can be prone to fighting and aggressiveness.
Joe Rogan has a little regard for the safety of others.
Brian red band,
irresponsible,
can't meet financial obligations.
Doesn't feel remorse or guilt.
That's none of us.
We definitely feel guilt.
Yeah,
so Brian,
you're most likely to be a psychopath.
Yeah,
most likely.
One percent of the general population sociopath,
four percent both suffer from I'm anti social personality disorder.
Both lack empathy.
Both demonstrate complete disregard for the social rules and behavior standards.
That's Brian both failed to feel any remorse or guilt.
That's not you at all.
A are violent.
So that's weird.
What's the difference?
Okay,
whatever.
See,
this is where I zone out.
Pop.
Pop psychology is a great word too,
because when it does get into the,
uh,
you don't want to become a part of the collective consciousness is,
as it says,
like people just scapegoat those things so much.
How many people in your life to just call themselves bipolar?
Look at this key difference.
Psychopaths are,
is likely to be educated and have a good career.
Sociopath is likely to be uneducated and unable to keep a steady job.
That's fucking interesting that they did.
A lot of these and psychopaths have controlled behavior.
Were sociopaths have erratic behavior.
Huh?
That's interesting.
Yeah,
that's fucking weird,
man.
We either way fucked up both highly manipulative,
impulsive,
spontaneous,
sociopath,
more sponsor of a more,
a spontaneous and psychopath,
more manipulative.
Fuck man.
You could find.
You could find yourself in a few of those and then things that are definitely
not you and all of them.
So,
you know what I mean?
Like I've definitely like,
there's definitely things in there where,
uh,
you know what?
I'm feeling a downtrodden.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm,
I'm like a highly manipulative person.
It'll make me upset at myself,
feel good.
But that just the next thing under there was like,
it's because I have personal tab,
I don't want to hurt people or anything like that.
You know what I mean?
I just feel like when you break variables down like that to like a two columns,
that's what I mean.
Four or $5 too much of yourself and none of yourself and all of it.
None of yourself.
Your complex man.
I mean you're a fucking year,
a lot of different things and you're a lot of different things from week to
week.
I mean you're a different person one week and then the next week you know,
things might be going way better in your life and you just.
I mean you might interact with the exact same person,
the exact same moment and a totally different way,
which makes you like pretty much a different person in a lot of ways that you
change all the time.
I think the real thing is empathy.
People who lack empathy,
that really,
really scares us.
People who will victimize other people grew and other people want to kill.
Other people want to do harm to other people.
Stopped going to be that kind of shit that freaks us out and that's what we're
really worried about.
We're worried about someone who goes after someone,
like someone who tries to harm them,
especially physically.
That scares the shit out of us.
Like someone,
someone could just like.
You've ever seen a video of this guy who was into just stab people in the ass?
No.
Yeah,
he stabbed a bunch of people and they got him on a security camera.
This guy was in like a retail store,
just walked us some duty tap,
tap,
tap that just shanks.
This guy in the ass like five,
six times before he even doesn't even know what's happening.
It's a black dude doing it to a white guy too,
which makes it extra spooky.
Like you the idea that you could just zig when you should have zagged and then
you run into some guy who has a buck knife and he just shoving it in your ass in
a department store like Dax possible.
Like you could run into that guy.
That kind of stuff freaks us out.
There was a in the,
in the East village maybe a year ago,
and they've had video of it,
which is pretty brutal.
It's just a little old Asian guy walking home like I think it was even that late
at night,
maybe like 10,
11:00 at night.
And I could be wrong about that,
but there's this video of this black dude goes up behind them.
It's a little
old Asian guy and he just starts beating him against the wall.
He just beat him to death on the middle of street out of nowhere,
unprovoked it comes,
comes up behind him and attack him.
The word was,
he was like,
you know,
all screwed up on drugs.
The kid like whack down on some,
on something.
But the police station is on my block,
uh,
in the East village.
So they brought them in there.
So we saw all the news vans and everything out there and you know,
me and my,
uh,
my buddy went over and we just kind of watched the guy come out and like to be a
part of something like that.
Like his face when they brought them out was like,
he definitely felt something.
Do you know what I mean?
Like he was,
he had like a kind of a scowl on his face,
but it didn't seem like remorse.
Just the face of a guy who was involved with just that violent have an action.
Like there's a death,
like a death happened and it was all and it wasn't even like a,
just like the idea of a,
you know,
we all fear those things.
And also I don't see myself do,
I don't see my,
I know,
I know fight or flight obviously,
but hitting someone in the head with a hammer,
like the thought of,
of what that would just do,
like the thing of,
like,
the actual physical action of that is mind blowing.
I couldn't possibly wrap my brain around just being there.
Just like how some people are just so smart.
You could barely understand half the fucking shit they're saying.
It's like when you talk to the particle physicist and I'm talking about cern and
these,
these experiments to doing,
trying to locate the large,
you know,
the,
um,
using the large Hadron collider and tried to locate the Higgs Boson particle,
like what the fuck,
man,
we really the same thing with this on dude's whose brains go off in a different
direction in a way that you can't even recommend.
Sure.
Couldn't even recognize the thought patterns of someone who just walks into a
walmart with an ax and just starts taking people out.
Like those people exist.
The Guy who got on the tower in an Austin,
Texas that one day,
the schools in the university and that was back in the sixties or the seventies,
and just started shooting people from the tower pole until they finally took him
out.
But fuck man.
Did you know with a Ted what the hell was in Bundy?
And then I said the Charles Whitman.
So you're talking about the guy going to tower Texas?
Yeah.
Apparently when he was autopsied he had a tumor on his temporal lobe.
Took away all of it.
So when it got big enough,
it took away all inhibitions.
He actually killed everything he saw on his way to that tower.
He killed it.
He killed his dog at home.
I think maybe his girl,
but he killed a few people on the way.
So it was just,
he would actually have been found not guilty today.
I've heard arguments about St Louis so he would not be found not guilty day
because that was actually like a physical problem that guy had.
But,
but you know,
can,
can you,
am I saying the right word here?
Behaviorally a teach someone to become a psychopath because we're in la now too,
which was always home of the crips,
bloods,
gang wars.
I mean you just take these kids that they're willing to like shoot in the crowds
indiscriminately and just kill people.
And then you know,
and later that night play madden.
Well you can,
if you raise them in a totally fucked
up way from the time they're born and the worst possible environment,
people imitate whatever atmosphere they're in.
If you're in an atmosphere that's filled with violence and horrific crime and
that becomes the norm and you get your respect by committing more violent and
more horrific crimes so that everyone's afraid of you and you become this bad
motherfucker with a lollipop would just shoot people in the face.
There's a lot of dudes like that because that's where they get that good feeling
that you get the good feeling of accomplishment by being the biggest fucking
psychopath around.
That's just a total failure of the environment that person's being developed in,
but that's also what they have to do in warm and
it was all about the psychopaths.
Do you see that fucking thing I posted on instagram today?
Look at this thing and pull up.
This image that I posted on instagram was from World War One.
Now look at this picture is 20 years before King Kong and the picture is a
propaganda picture depicting the Germans as savages.
This was about Germany CD.
He's got this club in his hand and the Club says Culture K,
u l t,
u r.
that's a like,
I guess I say it in Germany.
Maybe,
I don't know,
but it's supposed to represent German culture and this was,
this predated King Kong by 20 fucking years,
but it's a gorilla like with like a crown,
like a German,
a German helmet with a spike on the top of it and the grill is holding a woman
and her tits are.
Tits are allowed to show tits back then.
Even in an army propaganda film,
you've got to protect the tits and this gorilla with this club.
It says destroy this mad brute.
And then it says mayor list US army.
And if you go to a Joe Rogan on Instagram,
you could see it.
It's pretty crazy.
And it's in the sand that says America that I wonder if they,
they,
they kind of stole the idea for King Kong from that poster.
I wonder if that was a pretty well known poster back in the day and got me the
writer,
got the idea from that kid could have grown up seeing that,
you know?
And then 20 years later made a movie like it.
I mean,
I think,
but the idea of guerrilla,
you know,
at the time there,
another really interesting point at the time,
mountain gorillas were not even known to be real,
like mountain gorillas really only became known for sure in the early 19
hundreds.
So this is a relatively recent animal and a lot of ways like gorillas,
like there's always been talk of gorillas and different types of primates and
they've always known that chimpanzees existed and orangutans were very confusing
to people in the early 18 hundreds.
But when they were documenting all the different animals,
they didn't definitively document the mountain gorilla until the early 19
hundreds.
So you're looking at something probably if,
I guess that's supposed to represent a mountain gorilla or some kind of gorilla,
you're looking at something that was like a relatively recent idea to people.
This picture of a gorilla and it's also,
you're also looking at something that's only probably 50 years after the
invention of photography.
You know.
So I mean think about 50 years ago,
you know,
you're talking about like 1960 something,
right?
Think of that.
Think of the 19,
67 and we're still driving 19 sixties cars
around.
There's a lot.
Those are classic cars.
That was when the fucking full photograph was invented for them and here they
are looking at this image of a gorilla carrying a woman like whoa.
Like the idea of a.
A gorilla was pretty recent,
but that's Germany.
Getting that crazy like France and England were supposed to be civilization and
Germany.
These were mad barbarians from the Roman days.
Like that's what the Germanic tribes.
That's what we thought of Germans in the 19 hundreds.
They connected them to barbarians.
Really?
Yes.
Isn't that amazing?
So much so that when we went to war with them,
they couldn't have been more sleek.
It was such like a.
It was probably,
you know,
they were so advanced in so many words,
so much engine weaponry and all that shit.
They were like pretty well.
To this day,
the automobile industry there,
their cars are some of the most advanced cars in the world.
The Germans make Mercedes,
they make BMW and they make Porsche.
I mean,
we're done.
Those are like the three,
like if you've,
if you had to pick our top three most advanced,
best engineered high end cars,
those are the three.
Like those are the top of the Ferrari's are bad ass,
but everybody knows that fucking thing is going to break.
If you,
if you're one of those guys bump into someone,
you buy a fucking Ferrari like bitch,
you know you can't go to vegas and that thing,
you're going to be halfway in the desert and sudden bang,
Bang,
Bang one blah blah blah blah blah blah,
blah blah.
If he seen that car that goes on air like blow or belief or something like that,
it goes 100 miles on air and it has a compressor in it that takes four hours to
charge.
You just plug it in or you can go to a gas station and if they have like the,
like the compressor for,
you could fill it up in four minutes.
Do you got to be kidding now.
And what's crazy is that it's already big in the UK.
They're just now making a plant and whole Wiley and it's only cost $10,000.
That's a game changer.
Especially on the.
Yeah,
it's probably the CEO because on shark tank and they all in it.
If you have a really strong longer,
right.
That should be like your workout everyday is pumping your car or airplane ramp,
but I mean you're going to have that.
That's mostly people in smart cars in New York.
It's terrifying.
That doesn't even have two wheels in the front.
That's a bike.
I don't even know if that's the same one.
I saw a bike with a helmet and recall immobile.
That's what it is.
The air pod.
The air part was on shark tank.
Oh yeah.
I guess that's it.
Let's see a video on this pitch that looks to me like a bike wearing a helmet.
That's all it looks like.
That does not look real and it doesn't definitely doesn't look like something
you'd be safe and how does that pass all the crash standards and all that shit,
but that was one of the things like all the sharks didn't invest in it because
you know they don't.
They only have three prototypes of this and there it was just about to go into
manufacturing.
So they haven't done the actual test yet.
Why don't you just google it?
Jamie just googled airpod video because we can't just go on their facebook page
and click on every link.
You're going to get this dog shit.
This is how we made the seat.
The seat.
Yeah.
You can travel a hundred miles from the foam.
That's very light so we can drive forever.
I look at this fucking thing.
Drive around.
It's crazy too.
That gets no traction.
That's a scary.
Imagine if you were on black ice in that piece of shit.
Can you imagine taking it?
Same thing.
If you could pedal pedal something that's probably pretty good,
but could probably handle a boost the pedal be a boost.
It's a moped.
Look how you get out though that said Jetson Dick Dat,
Dat,
you control it using a joy stick,
like a video game
trippy.
That's true.
But what if you want to text and drive?
You can't even do that.
You need two hands to control this pitch.
I wonder the middle,
like maverick from a control of the joystick,
that's probably a good idea to keep people from texting and driving.
Make them a controlled the car with two joysticks.
Year one fraternity for grilling.
Straightened back.
But you can't look slick.
Like if you're rolling your six four and you got your hand up like this.
But lending my six full and all the hookers saying,
let me write that long arm hold onto the top of the steering wheel.
Sup Boys Suck.
You know,
even with the windows go down.
The fucking window is blasting yourself with music.
I think the front wheel,
it's about as big as a tic TAC toe.
Cartwheel.
It's a wagon.
Sounded like a child's toy.
We'll.
Yeah.
So small.
I mean look at this weird fucking engine too,
but hey man,
do you think it has heat?
That's a good question,
right?
Instead of heat doesn't have anything.
How weird is this?
Watch that thing.
Fill up with air.
What if someone comes along and just shoots a hole in your air tank and he
fucking explode?
Right.
Oxygen,
oxygen.
What's interesting though is that this is even possible.
Can you imagine somebody like Porsche or somebody getting behind in this kind of
idea of we don't have.
We're not even using fuel.
We're using air.
That's fun.
Nuts.
Yeah.
Well,
you know the problem with that and that,
how are you generating that air?
Like what are you doing to get that compressed air and how much fossil fuels are
involved in making that air compressor through that process might require some
shit like that.
I mean maybe they can do it with solar.
Maybe there's a way to power some sort of a generator with solar that pumps air.
That seems possible.
If that's true,
boy,
that would be like the greenest shit of all time,
but it would also be real.
Oh Wow.
There's a back seat or no,
it seems like she climbed in the back or is this a different one that was just
next to each other.
Oh,
so there's more.
More,
more than one model.
Do you ever watch that shark tank show?
No,
it's actually a pretty decent.
It's like find,
find a lot of things in there that
are like this company called Bagel bites in New York now,
like addicted to them and they just send you all these different kinds of bagels
and they're just like little bagel balls with cream cheese in the middle of
them.
You put in your oven,
support that show 100.
I'm,
I support anybody who is encouraging people to come up with a good thing.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
Have you tried it?
Oh,
that's really good.
It's pretty hard.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Dallas diamond page.
I interviewed a Pto.
We,
we,
uh,
he gave me a copy of.
I've been doing it on the road.
Yeah.
It's a good thing to do in hotels in the road to the yoga.
Hard workout is hard to do.
I would have left a yoga three years ago and I'll show you a Hixon gracie
documentary called choke,
which shows hixon doing yoga and you realize like,
oh,
I think I have a weird idea about yoga because I think of all these chicks doing
it.
Yoga is hard,
man.
It's really good for your body and it's fantastic for your core.
See,
there's a lot of people that they,
and I was guilty of this myself for sure when you work out all sorts of
different ways,
but what you don't work out in your body's ability to move as one unit and one
unit and your flexibility and your body's like balance and sovereignty,
like where your body.
You could do whatever you want to do with your body like stand on one foot and
just stick your leg straight up in the air.
There's a lot of people that can lift.
I'll fuck load of weight.
There's a lot of people that can run upstairs and do laps on this fucking pool
back and forth,
and they're just animals,
but ask them to stand on one leg,
grab their foot and stick their foot straight up in air and then bounced.
They literally can't do it.
They can't balance their body like that.
It's because they don't have full control of the body and what Yoga gives you is
this weird control of your body when you get really good at Yoga,
like Hixon did you know,
like he was one of the reasons why he was one of the best Jujitsu guys in the
world.
It wasn't just that he knew every move there was.
It wasn't just that his dad was Leo Gracie.
He was one of the greatest Jujitsu artists.
One of the most important martial arts ever was also his physical abilities were
superior because he was into all that yoga and all this bodyweight stuff.
Like he would do all these crazy exercises.
Man.
He would do all these like balance beam things.
It's pretty dope.
There's a video of him on the beach in Santa Monica and he's doing like these
pistol squats on a balance beam,
holding his foot up and sticks his foot right above his head and he's a Jujitsu
master.
Put pull the video up.
It's hits,
hits.
Oh,
it's crazy to see because you think about what you can do with your body and you
think about like how much effort it would take to be able to do this with this
guy's doing right.
Diamond Dallas page in his fifties,
in the video,
standing on one leg and holding his leg up in the air.
Oh yeah.
And the way they pull it out to go up in the middle and you pull it out and it's
really impressive.
He's kidding.
Get even close to what he's doing,
but he's done is fix a lot of people's bodies.
A lot of times.
My back a lot.
My eye real annoying.
Lower back problems for like about a year and a half and it's made that much,
much better.
I bet it would.
My data would strengthen your entire core.
I'll show you machine after we get out of here.
I've got a thing in the back for lower backs.
It's called a reverse hyper.
It was made by this Guy Louie Simmons,
who's a world famous power lifter guru from Columbus,
Ohio and from west side barbell and westside.
Barbells is a organization that he came up with this machine that it works like
sort of like what your legs are hanging like.
You lean your upper body over like a table and your legs are dangling from the
waist down there dangling and they hook up to these rollers like a leg curl
machine sort of end with a straight leg.
You lift your leg all the way up and then you let it go down and as it's going
down it,
it pulls on your lower back.
It's like an active decompression,
so you lifted up.
It's strengthens.
He lifted down,
it decompresses lifted up its strength.
If you want to look at it folks,
it's called reverse hyper.
You can get it online.
I bought mine from a company called rogue fitness.
This is all the crossfit stuff.
They have all that cool shit,
but I'm telling you this reverse hyper has been amazing for my back.
It's so good.
Have you ever done.
I was at my apartment in New York is too small to store one,
but I want to get an inversion table so have to back there.
One that you do from the waist down.
You like lean forward on and I'll show you both of them after.
I'm so curious.
Hang upside down like a bad every day.
I do it every,
every day,
every day.
I do it every day for five minutes every day.
Every day.
Every time I work out,
every time I lift weights,
especially if I lift anything heavy,
like if I do squats or anything like that in of when you do it,
do it right after I'm done and I do it for as long as I can until I feel
relaxed.
I just want my back to open up because everything you feel that happened to you
actually feel it like it a little ways at all.
If you actually feel you pulled out that noise,
see this,
that's what you're hoping for.
Is that what you're hoping for?
A magic cure,
but it's not.
That's not really.
That's not.
Nothing's really happening there.
That's like nitrogen being released.
It's not really fixing anything.
It just sounds cool.
Yeah.
I love the sound like when I get go to the chiropractor and I get cracked,
I love the sound,
but the reality is that's not what's fixing anything.
What's fixing is the adjustment of the spine and what's fixing when you're.
When you're doing that,
that conversion table inversion table,
it's the decompression of your muscles like your muscles relaxing and stretching
be so you gotta be able to actually concentrate on relaxing your lower back and
most people can't.
Most people,
they tense up so even when they lie hanging by their ankles,
like so,
one of the reasons why some doctors erroneously think it's not effective,
they go,
well,
you're just going to support it with your back anyway.
I'm a little,
but if you understand how your body works,
you can relax that area and I feel a great difference between holding it tents
and relaxing that there.
I feel the stress on that lower back area and it's lengthening the muscles.
It's pulling them and stretching them in a way that it's very hard to stretch
those muscles.
It's very hard to stretch them that way.
You know like your body's malleable man,
like you can.
The reason why some people are super,
super flexible.
There's a little bit of genetics involved there,
but a lot of it is just pushing just hard work and pushing on
the flexibility just everyday making it move a little bit more,
move a little bit more.
Like when you see a dude with crazy holes in their ear,
that's like a.
You can do that shit to your body.
You can stretch things out.
You can put a plate in your lip,
you can.
You can do that also,
that kind of thing.
Your neck,
yeah,
you can lengthen your neck with those wires.
Those crazy ladies put on,
but you can also kind of stretch your body out that way too.
There's soft tissue manipulation,
so only certain amount you could get away with,
but you can,
if you push it hard enough,
long enough,
you're really dedicated.
You can stretch a lot of shit and one of the problems that people have with
their lower backs especially is their hamstrings.
Like if your hamstrings are really tense,
that puts a tremendous amount of pressure on your lower back.
And it also limits your mobility.
It limits the way your body can move around and that also puts pressure on your
lower back.
You stretch it all with your,
your hamstrings.
I do,
yeah.
I've been,
I've taken a lot more to stretching.
I,
I did crossfit for two years and I lost a bunch of weight during which there was
great in that regard.
But uh,
the damage,
like speed,
power lifting is not a good idea.
Fucked up your back.
That's what I think.
Did it.
Yeah.
I mean just like,
you know,
you would be one of them swinging kettle bells sometimes,
just like,
not even that.
I don't really think kettle bells were much of the things I,
for some reason I was kind of able to focus like my stance on kettlebells
because it was never that heavy,
but things where they,
you know,
they want you to do like,
like cleans or like a snatch and then they show you the form for 20 minutes and
then they go now as fast as you can for eight minutes,
you know,
and the best guys done this and you don't want to be a loser like that guy.
So you know,
be as good as this,
you know,
try to do it fast.
And how many people drop those weights and sacrificed?
How many people do you see drop weights in their head.
I actually know all the injuries that.
So people missing box jumps let's people get hurt with the.
Most of their shins get busted up on those.
Well,
you know,
that's the probably the easiest to fix.
Assist to cut in a bruise.
The real hard stuff to fix it.
The back stuff,
you know when you start doing power lifting in like large repetition movements,
fast,
fast impresses.
Yeah,
you lose,
you know,
the most important thing with power lifting,
the most important thing is proper form.
That's the most important thing by far and you should never abandoned that ever.
And that's one of the things that people criticized.
Crossfit for.
Steve Maxwell,
who's a good friend of mine,
who's a fantastic trainer,
probably one of the most knowledgeable people I've ever met when it comes to
like fitness training,
it's always on top of the latest modalities,
different techniques and stuff like that.
He hates it.
He thinks that I can see.
I,
I give it.
It's due because like with the right now,
I die it much harder and I do more yoga than I would say I do like,
you know,
heavyweight training.
I try to do more stuff like that,
you know what I mean,
like cardio and stuff.
I definitely,
yeah,
that's insane.
Watch the video though.
It's insane.
Watch him,
watch him work out on the beach because it's fucking ridiculous.
He just pistol squats.
This is all different things that he's doing,
but you got to see the um,
the gymnastics in Santa Monica.
That's a totally different video,
just like channing tatum and foxcatcher
he.
This is,
this is from choke.
This is a different one.
It's a,
it's different footage.
Um,
it's,
it's him on the balance bar in Santa Monica beach.
He's doing that kind of shit,
but he's doing it while he's walking on a balance bar.
It's nuts.
But also those,
those kind of like applied
like muscle skills or greg,
like American Ninja Warrior.
That's such a cool show or the original.
You don't think any units need like this stuff,
like mixing Gracie to American warriors.
Joe.
Such a cool show.
No,
not just the idea that you could like,
like the concept of hanging off the side of a building terrifies me because
there's no chance I'll pull myself up if I catch a ledge by my fingertips and
effect,
those guys can send on their fingertips is fucking bonkers.
Those free climbers are fucking spooky that those guys are doing.
Like that dude we had on Alex Honnold,
the guy who goes up the side of mountains backwards.
That guy's insane.
Have you seen me?
Have you ever
park horror to good way to break your neck?
Did you ever see the Russian guys that go on the crane and just do like chiclets
we played every one of those.
It makes my legs quiver.
Watching the videos.
Yeah.
My feet go numb.
Couldn't even imagine trying to do that whole body starts shaking because I'm
watching them says video the other day of this guy that goes out on this ledge
of this hotel,
like super high up and he just starts jumping from one like patio,
like had that like this little part on it.
Just from one to another.
Talking about that new cell phone video.
Is that it?
Yeah,
it's for the Samsung Galaxy is the galaxy note or galaxy s six.
That was a Neil Brennan doing the jump into fucking park cooler master.
Yeah.
The guy like he straps the video camera eight straps the camera on him and then
turns the video on and then jumps from building to building.
But it might be bullshit.
It might be CGI and I'm not exactly sure because he's doing some fucking insane
jumps.
I'm not exactly sure if he's really doing those jobs right here.
Oh No,
you're not.
Hide it.
That's never seen this.
I've seen this.
Yeah.
Look at this.
This is an edge camera video.
Look at this fucking guy,
man.
I mean,
it seems real.
This is the one I'm talking about right here.
This
takes a photo of their food guys jumping off of buildings and shit taking photos
of food,
but would you jump?
You could definitely jump,
you know,
four feet with a run.
You could definitely jump four feet without a doubt.
You can do that so you can jump.
You can jump over a distance of four feet.
You know,
for a fact.
You should absolutely do that.
I wouldn't jump four feet from building the building by me.
I just got.
I mean,
there's definitely a,
an amount of money.
I guess I will do that for I suppose,
but I mean like I would still be married.
I'd still be emotionally panicked,
like going to do it.
Even if I know,
even though I know I can jump
significantly further,
I'm checking my feet.
How many,
how many feet wide do you think this table is?
It's three.
What do you think?
This is not more than three.
What is this?
Four feet wide?
Yeah.
See,
I could definitely jump over that with avant and everything like that.
Of course.
Even just standing broad jump.
Definitely jump over that.
But if below was like hundred store.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
My hands are sweating dude.
I just said that my hands started sweating because then I'd have to assume it's
real.
I have to assume is that Brian's video will make you faint and I gave it to
Jamie.
No,
but this is the one I'm talking about.
Look how high that is.
And he just starts jumping from one corner to one coronary and at the end he has
to stop at.
Do you have that?
But you could,
um,
you know,
have you ever in your.
I guess probably if you go on really hard,
but if you've fallen off of a chin up bar ever know,
but you still would not want to like take that.
So you're,
you're confident in your,
in your,
in your pull ups.
And you wouldn't want to do it over those.
Just land on your feet.
Here it is.
Check this.
Oh my God.
No,
he's not doing this.
What is he doing?
Oh,
this is fucked up.
Oh my God.
Dude.
Look,
they're dripping.
My hands are dripping.
Feel my hands.
They're fucking soaking wet right now.
It's a real anxiety.
But it says for a guy you don't know where anything was.
The fact that that guy's out of his mind.
The fuck is he?
How much would someone have to pay you to do this?
Never.
No.
I would faint.
Yeah.
This.
There's no amount of money for that.
I would suck Dick.
I don't think I have that much faith in my coordination.
Which sect?
X before doing that?
Probably.
Yes.
Yeah.
How many dicks have as many as they want?
You know
you can't die.
You'd have to.
You would know halfway through the deck.
This deck is spoiled,
right?
Sir?
Do you have on?
Because I am not going to get tricky gnosis from your dicks or a gun.
There is nuts for a stamp.
The date stamp fucking Gardia from your,
your your Dick Dying.
Transgenders that have fake pussy.
He's like,
if they feel like they can't get a period that they're like,
oh,
only if I could get it to do something else.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't think I'm super thrilled with it.
And also there's that weird thing is because it does it being made where the Deq
was.
So the,
it's also an oddly placed vagina usually also it's kind of like high up.
It's where the decal seen one in real life.
Do you think they'd put just chip packets in there and they squeezed us to make
it feel like,
you know,
like I think they probably pretend here's Hickson crazy.
As crazy as that sounds crazy that sounds.
Do that.
But I mean like
they like,
you know,
girls who want to become men.
Wear a fucking fake Dick all day.
Yeah.
Look at this difference.
Yeah,
that is true.
There's a lot of girls who do do that.
Maybe putting some may want to put
exploding blood packs and the vagina.
Those things thinking she wanted to be a vampire or when you were a kid,
look at this fucking balance.
This guy has.
He just sat down on it.
He's putting his foot down and then watch.
He's going to stand up for working for it though too.
He's not watch this,
but he's because he's standing up on one day from his ass down.
I'd also like a rounded pole.
Looks like.
No,
no.
That's flat on top.
Like balls.
Doe.
Now Watch how he does this though.
This is insane.
That's crazy.
He stands up and then once he gets all the way to the top,
then he doesn't split.
He grabs his foot.
It's crazy.
It's fucking balance is amazing
and that was why one of the.
You mean one of the reasons why he was so good,
like he had a combination of everything.
Look,
get that.
Get the fuck out of here,
man.
That dude's doing a split.
Look at this shit.
Standing on a balance beam.
I was like,
that's like the ultimate control of your body right there.
If you can do that,
you could basically do anything.
He's the greatest Jujitsu fighter of all time to like widely recognized by
almost everybody ever as being a great,
greatest gracie.
I don't think it's a coincidence that it's also he can do ridiculous things with
his body that like,
I bet Lebron James can't do that.
I bet coby Brian can't do that,
you know,
but what he can do,
that's a very unusual.
I wouldn't bet a GSP could probably do that.
I think things similar to close.
Yeah.
George is a pretty amazing athlete.
He jumps up on those little messages in between them and used.
It goes up and down.
I mean,
that's like.
Yeah.
Well he also,
he's very flexible too.
That's a big flexibility move.
You have to be really flexible just to be able to hold your leg up there like
that.
You know,
George is pretty flexible.
Did you see the Pacquiao?
Mayweather fight?
Yeah.
What'd you think?
I um,
it was just boring.
I thought you said you liked it.
Yeah.
But I think that uh,
most people were disappointed,
right?
I just was bored.
I just call.
I called it very easily from the beginning.
I never believe I asked you if you're already talking.
I know it seems like that UFC has.
MMA is really spoiled boxing for me because I,
I just,
I mean it's not like Mike Tyson days.
It wasn't exciting like that where you know,
not going to be,
but that was the best at their best.
That's the best boxers right now.
And if that's your best,
why?
Why are we watching 100 bucks?
That's twice as much as UFC.
The UFC $60.
Okay.
Let's still deaf.
It's a million fights.
Yeah,
tons of.
Over the course of the night,
you get free fights,
but don't you think?
Like everybody says,
fuck this.
I never watched boxing again.
I think that's bullshit.
I think they will still watch it,
but I'm not going to pay 100 bucks ever,
but who's going to be a real?
Who's gonna?
Who's gonna tear through again,
like a Tyson.
That's what you need.
You need somebody with that kind of vicious knockout,
so you need to bring excitement to it.
One
thing,
there was excitement around this fight,
but I never fully understood why.
I really was like,
I think I called that from the second they announced the fight.
I go mayweather winds by the.
What about Canelo Alvarez?
I'm not familiar with a bad motherfucker.
He's fighting.
Next week is fighting this upcoming Saturday.
They're going to show the rematch.
The floyd mayweather fight on Hbo and then he's gonna fight Saturday or Friday.
I don't know.
I'd rather use from Australia.
Right.
Let's cut.
Boxing match I watched was uh,
Chris Algieri beating that,
uh,
the Russian providing the coffee.
Yeah.
That was a fun fight to watch.
Did you see a lucas matea say versus product off providing the coffin.
Matisa go to a war for 12 rounds.
It's fucking crazy.
I mean it was a crazy fight.
That's like the kind of fight that everybody wanted from a pack out and
mayweather.
Like just show a couple of,
just a few minutes.
Show highlights of the [inaudible] providing a cough fight.
This fight was like some crazy rock 'em sock.
'Em robots.
Rocky five.
Like it was a movie fight and,
and all of a UFC and boxing or MMA and boxing.
For me,
I'd say one of my top five fights of all time is a boxing diego corral is versus
um.
Oh,
what was his name?
It's one of those three names I believe.
I know who you're talking about.
Taylor,
Jonathan Taylor.
Thomas.
He got pissed at the world.
Was getting wobbly towards the center.
I know you're talking about.
I mean they fought in a,
in a phone booth.
They said,
you know,
for it was insane.
And then,
you know,
it was a back and forth knockouts Kinda like that.
Pat Barry Check Congo thing.
This is the,
this is these two guys fighting him and this is providing the coffin.
It was a crazy fight.
They smashed heads right there.
But this,
this was like one.
If you want to watch like a blood and guts fight like everybody wanted the
mayweather fight to be.
You got to watch this fight because it was fucking incredible.
She's,
I mean these guys just back and forth,
beat the fuck out of each other.
Providing the cough takes a punch better than any living human that's ever
walked the face of this fucking planet.
And when he's done,
he looks like a,
like an Asian,
like dry cleaner lady,
old.
But I mean he really does.
And he's always stretched out.
His face is bizarre.
He looks like they pulled him out of like a wooly mammoth Tusk in the middle of
the fucking Himalayan or some shit.
He's such a stud though.
So it's like a fucking animal as a fighter.
And He,
uh,
they did,
um,
uh,
took photos of his drug test after the fight and his urine was black.
I mean the from below,
like coke,
like Coca Cola,
that's what it's piss looked like from this fight because this fight was so
crazy.
I mean it was just like one of the nuttiest fights I've ever seen in my life.
And that was the kind of fight that Jose Luis Castillo,
right?
Wasn't that it was.
Yeah.
Deal Corollas.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's it.
And they went back and forth,
back and forth,
and they own each other was so good.
God Damn.
Yeah.
He had some great fucking fighting and Diego has died.
And like not crazy long after that.
He died in a motorcycle accident.
No,
yeah,
he was a wild dude.
It was wild dudes.
Just fucking
but then don't make it.
Then they'll make the movie of his life and he'll be like,
I was just starting my charity work.
I'm done.
I'm done with this crazy fight game.
I'm going to preserve my family and stop cheating on my lady.
What I'm going to do right now.
Some of the help the little kids coming up and then it'll be some kid drinking,
laughing.
He turns a corner and smashes into them and there's a lot of people that
complain about the end of a,
you know that guys being dripped dragged over the coals now the he's dead now,
but to Chris,
the American sniper guy,
Chris Kyle was like the same thing.
It was like,
I'm going to go help this wacky guy out and she's like,
you shouldn't do it.
He goes,
hey,
everyone deserves help.
Every kid home that day.
I bet he was just like,
you know,
they probably all here.
I was like,
fuck you fucking cunt.
Well now I have to leave your fucking concept.
That's why I asked for breakfast to be done an hour ago when I got in the
shower.
You twat I'll be back at seven.
You fucking dumb or change your attitude before I get back dead.
Oh God.
You never know man.
You watched a movie about someone's life.
They,
most of the shit they're saying they just did not see it.
Do you try to not leave town or,
or hang up on it?
I,
I never,
I always say with like,
I think any girlfriend I've ever had or if it's like,
let's not let me not leave town.
Getting on a plane while we're in a fight.
Like I've thrown that all away.
I will absolutely get on a plane.
And then while I'm on the plane,
I'm like,
if this plane goes down,
let's get a fucking ruin the rest of her life.
Fuck her.
That's so crazy.
So this Baltimore thing,
what was the,
um,
what did they do to this guy?
Because there's a catalyst.
You mean like the world was a,
he,
he died in a police van,
right?
They injured his,
they hurt his back,
his neck and spinal cord failure,
right?
Yeah,
but I had read from a very
non credible source that he was already injured.
That's not true.
It's not true.
So he died from an injury he sustained in.
So all the stuff that everybody has said about it being all the fake rumors,
those motherfuckers with their fake stories.
Dangerous.
My broken heart of that was hearing other guys that were in the,
in the van to like the other criminals or you know,
alleged criminals that were in the van with them,
like giving their account of it was always great because it goes,
it was welcome him and hurt him himself
was of course the cups did.
He can't hurt himself like that.
Yeah.
That's not the guy you want to kill himself.
NBC News Dot Com says disputed report and then Freddie Gray hurt himself in
police van.
Question Mark.
That is not journalism.
You shouldn't
be able to do that.
You shouldn't be able to say disputed report and then the title,
Freddie Gray hurt himself in police van.
Question Mark,
you just getting off the hook.
You haven't done the fucking work and trying to get the story out.
He tried to get clicks before you've done the work.
You don't know if that story.
Fuck,
you can't do that.
Like that sneaky shit for NBC News Dot Com.
That's really sneaky shit because that's not a story.
You know what that is.
This disputed report on a new site.
How about you do some fucking journalism.
How about you follow up and get an actual report?
How will your.
What you're doing is if you say something like that,
people like me just read the headline and start repeating it.
I already,
he hurt himself in the van.
I already tried to hurt something.
The best guy hurt himself in the van.
Okay.
And that burden down the dry cleaners.
The best example of how uh,
easy that shit goes is,
or what was it?
There was,
wasn't there as a comic at one point that was like accused of something and
everyone just says like,
he did it.
Who they go,
I can't remember.
Yeah,
no,
no.
It was a comic a who lives out here I think.
Oh yeah.
But a
terrible example,
let's,
let's keep moving.
Let's do another one years.
Did you hear about having to do have a kid in la that got shot by the cops?
A 13 year old kid or it was 19 year old kid is crying for his mom armed crime
for his mommy before he fucking died.
The cops thought they thought he had a gun,
shot him through a fucking screen window.
Like there's som,
you know,
you standing there,
he's gonna be on bang.
They just shoot them.
It just wasn't doing anything.
He wasn't a criminal at all.
Total accidental death from some incompetent person that happened to be a police
officer.
And now this,
you know,
well hideous can become police officers.
Suppose Got Duke Lacrosse thing is a good example because people still say use
that as an example of like a rapey situations like telling Duke Lacrosse team.
But yeah,
didn't happen.
And they're always kind of like things people still say that,
well people are terrified of fraternities actually doing something like that.
So the Duke Lacrosse case is just one of those.
But like the Uva,
the University of Virginia thing that rolling stone printed this huge article
about never happened.
They just did shit journalism.
They failed at every level when it comes to dirt and this goddamn rolling stone.
But because it's such a sensitive subject and people are really sensitive about
calling out someone that may have actually been a victim like being wrong and.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
And saying you were in a victim and it turns out there were people are so
terrified of that that they actually skirt away from the real journalism,
you know?
And that's what's happened because you.
Yeah,
exactly.
If you don't want to get like,
you don't wanna get in trouble because if they're right.
Yeah.
But that,
you know,
that thing that the Duke Lacrosse case,
that was one of Nancy graces pets,
those bars,
right?
That girl,
they tit,
that girl did terrible things.
I mean,
she never apologized to them.
I mean she was flat out accusing them of that on television.
You know,
you can.
That's kind of the same thing.
It's not journalism.
A story's not done.
Did you don't know unless you were there,
you got to fuck and get all your ducks in a row.
And even then,
man,
people lie.
There's a lot of weird shit going on when,
whenever there's a story and then there's two different sides of that story.
Boy,
this gets tricky.
Trying to figure out who's telling the truth and who's not telling the truth and
what is what like fuck man.
Just to like all the only witnesses were the or the groups that were there.
But those behind closed doors,
accusations are fucking meth.
That's so man.
Never want to be on those.
Yeah,
no shit.
And it's also,
it's weird the difference in like the stories that catch,
you know,
there's stories that catch fire and then everybody wants to walk in the street
and protest like this kid in La,
this is not catching fire for whatever reason,
you're barely hearing about this.
Baltimore's burning down.
Baltimore is burning down and the guy who was in police custody is an admitted
criminal,
right?
Like everybody's kind of admitting that this guy has done crimes before and this
is just simply a police brutality issue.
But this kid who got shot in La isn't even a criminal.
He's just a kid.
It was just a mistake like this is.
That's terrifying to me that just willing to shoot that 12 year old boy in
Cleveland,
the guy gets out of the car,
a cop who was taken off of a,
a different police squad because he was dangerous because they didn't.
They just like.
They were like,
you gotta get the fuck out of here.
They kicked them off and another department hires this guy.
He gets out of a car in two seconds.
He's shooting at a 12 year old with a gun.
And not saying that being a cop isn't a fucking insanely difficult job.
And not saying that I,
I,
I've said many times I don't think anybody can do it right.
I think it's just way too much stress and way too much pressure.
But my point is how weird is it that some stories catch at some stories don't
like some stories.
They just,
they just slip right by.
You hear about the guy getting shot by the cops and there's no protests and
everything.
It just becomes another story.
It just becomes another statistic and then Freddie Gray boom,
or that kid in Ferguson,
boom,
Michael Brown,
boom.
It's just like catches and then the fucking protest.
It gets crazy and everybody just goes nuts over say cleveland.
So that kind of town.
But it is about the South Carolina one where the guy got shot.
They didn't burn.
They didn't.
Bri,
that guy got shot in the back.
Man,
that guy shot in the back and there's a fucking video of it,
but there's no crazy riots like there are in Baltimore.
It's just,
it's mob mentality,
man.
If he can get them off to to start like calming each other down like it spreads
that way.
You know what I mean?
Like let's take this to the streets.
Peaceful pro.
But if like if the controlling interest of people start going out there and just
like kicking in cop car windows,
that's the way it's going to go.
I that found that like I don't think there's anything good about the method that
was terrifying.
Watching people like.
And again,
if this was so much wrapped around like we're,
we're writing because we're
pissed off,
we're not going to take it anymore.
Like high five.
You see people laughing,
eating candy in the background while they're stomping on fucking cop cars.
And it's such like a.
It really is terrifying.
It's third world,
the third world.
I think the cops leave those cars there.
I really do.
I think they leave those cards there as like something to take their anger out
on.
Leave them a ca.
I mean in street fighter is if you give them a cop car to destroy and they have
those cars are insured,
it's a bonus level and they,
it gives them something to destroy.
And I really think that.
I really think that that's probably a strategy and a lot of ways.
Take a cop car,
leave it in an area where you know,
there's going to be some protests and just let him fuck it up.
You know,
Baltimore mayor gave those who wish to destroy space to do that.
I got in trouble for saying that,
but okay.
But what she said was she was criticized because they thought that she was
actually giving the green light to go ahead and riot by a mayor,
not trying to calm people down,
but instead by saying something like that,
the the interpretation was that what she did was she almost gave them like a
license to go out and smash it.
She's a black lady.
Yeah,
she's cute.
We gave those who wished to destroy space to do that as well.
Hmm.
She's black,
right?
Yes.
Why You keep having to bring that up,
man,
because she asked because she,
I don't see color.
I feel because I feel bad.
She has to answer like for so many things also.
Do you know what I mean?
Let me read that again.
Yeah,
no,
I hear you.
Look at what's in this quote though,
because while trying to make sure that we are protected from the cars and other
things that were going on,
we gave those who wish to destroy space to do that as well and we worked very
hard to keep that balance and to put ourselves in the best position to
deescalate.
That sounds to me that she's very pragmatic.
See,
know what I read it in context,
what that sounds to me like she's a pragmatic woman and what she did was she
made a calculation and decided that these guys are going to destroy things and
maybe that was admitting that they left some cop cars.
They're too smart.
Move Right?
Take a loss for the greater good.
Maybe you know,
but there's the,
you mean the greater good?
But they burnt a lot of shit.
They smashed a lot of things.
A lot of cops got injured.
Fuck.
Being a cop man.
It's too hard this day in age.
Fuck that.
We need them though.
That's what's crazy.
You know,
I'm really going to say this is one of the things like,
well,
who's going to do it a certain size,
certain personality that's going to go do it.
You know,
I mean there's,
I guess there's multiple ports now I can do it,
but a lot of times ends up being the same guy.
You know,
it's,
it can you know,
and obviously the abusive people or when it becomes a problem,
but the really calm people,
they're super valuable,
super valuable asset to the community.
If you have a really good calm cop who actually can deal with shit,
good luck finding one of those.
Good luck being that guy too.
It's a hard road and you're not going to get nearly the respect that you feel
like you deserve or putting your fucking life on the line on a daily basis,
breaking
up family disputes and stopping crime and break ins and fucking car jackings and
all kinds of crazy shit you have to deal with.
Everybody's lying to you.
I mean some of the worst things.
I was one of the.
When a cop really does buddy up to you and starts like opening up his weird
moral like world,
like where his morals are to you.
It's,
it always blows my mind.
I've had them say things like,
yeah,
it sucks these fucking homeless around here.
You know,
we used to be able to beat their ass,
but now it's like they're watching us everywhere.
You know?
Really.
I've heard him say a one guy was bragging to me that he's never had even tried
out.
I was smoking weed in his presence and he was a guy I wish I could smoke again,
man,
but you know,
they just test this all the time.
He goes,
but you can check my arrest records,
man.
I've never had a never arrested anyone for.
We'd never arrested for a Dui.
And I was like,
what?
Like no man,
like every Dui.
Yeah,
exactly.
It be trying to court make some correlation to me that I,
that I saw got drunk on the road there at night,
pretty short drunk sinking or whether or not she'd call them.
And so I got beside him in the lane,
backed up and stayed behind them,
watching them weave in and out of the land.
I couldn't tell if he was drunk or he's tired because you keep it up for awhile
and then he would drift and then they come back in and keep it up.
And then he was good.
It was hard to tell,
but it's disturbing.
It's fuck.
It's like all these cars are flying around going 70 miles an hour and this one
guy is not fully in control.
I had to call a few times just because every time I come home it's that time,
you know the bars are closing and so once in a while you just have to do it
because you see how bad it is.
Like all right,
that's ridiculous.
I called in once,
called him once,
coming down the one-on-one.
Some fucking guy was just taking two,
three lanes at a time,
just go straight across and then back on straight for a little bit,
a little bit of wiggle drift to the right back on straight,
straight,
straight way.
I mean he was fucked up and I knew that that guy was going to crash and I called
the cops.
I don't know what happened,
never saw it.
I did watch a guy.
I was going 70 miles an hour and this guy fucking flew by me on the highway the
other day,
just one long.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
I mean,
dude,
it was a crowded highway and dude had to be going a buck 20,
easy,
easy buck 20 and then right behind him the fucking cops were racing him the
entire time.
This asshole like thought he was like being Joe Slick and driving fast with a
car behind him and that car was a cop car.
So they,
they hit the lights and they're right behind them.
Oh my God.
He was driving so fast because I was watching this.
I was like,
this is not like an empty road on the way to Vegas.
There's no one in front of you and your fucking listening to radar.
Love this.
This is the one on one in Hollywood,
you know,
at 7:30 at night,
very crowded road and this guy was following Elian.
It's so that the scientists in on that shit.
You know what I mean?
Like those things,
they don't.
They end bad a lot.
Yeah,
they do.
Car Chases are fucking terrifying for cops to imagine if you're a company
plowing or someone and kill them when you're trying get some bad guy flood.
It happens.
Of course it happens with your fucking going 150 miles an hour,
whatever the hell you going going around corners and how,
how good exactly as they're driving.
Did you oversee the,
uh,
those videos of cops getting hit by cars while they're like checking ids and
said,
oh yeah,
that's awful.
I mean,
where they stand for that is ridiculous.
Almost most of them don't do that anymore.
They stand on the outside,
they go on the other side.
But there's a danger issue,
you know,
like when you're approaching cars,
you've got to see someone's hands.
You got to make sure that they don't have any weapons on them.
Every cop has to approach every car.
Like,
this is the guy that might keep you from seeing your family.
Again,
that's just a crazy job,
man.
It's a crazy way to make a living.
It is a shame because they said those videos.
That's why I said I've,
I've actually never had cops be very helpful to me or nice to me ever.
It's very rare.
Yeah.
It's very weird.
I.
Well Look at you.
You look like a fucking monster.
I mean,
yeah,
it's a fucking torture basement.
This brass again.
What's,
uh,
what's under that?
Carson,
Jay,
nothing.
It's just carpet.
Just 14.
Philippians boys were pulled from a trunk and this man's do from pope fixing
that.
Bring up the gimp guys putting up the gimp.
You one of the guys,
right?
A grown man with long hair.
I was like,
hm.
You don't follow the rules,
do you?
What else do you not follow the rules on,
sir?
It's usually the button which is.
I do play by the rules in a button.
Well that's the new rule.
You get a man thing the top,
like a pony pony.
And then on top of the girl up here and you heard the newest trend for women is
actually putting it in Old Lady Hair Bun and actually dying your hair graze
that.
Like people are dying their hair.
Great.
I met a girl that's so stupid.
Nose rings looked weird and that's a high pants as mom.
Gene shared done yet,
you know,
there's always going to be something.
People are always exhausted with the options that are available and they're just
like,
look,
I just need something to do.
I'm going,
fuck it.
I'm going to fucking tattoo my face.
I thought those guys on a lockup raw or something where they tattoo their eyes.
Oh yeah.
I've seen a tattoo.
The wetsuit on black
dye.
Their hair gray for the granny hair.
Well,
if you're fucking hot as shit.
Like those girls.
Yeah,
you can do silver.
It's not even great.
Who's going to get mad?
Like a hot those girls.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
They're so hot.
Who gives a fuck if they have gray hair,
you shave your head.
You know,
like I was say like when someone say,
do you think girls attractive?
There's a lot of girls that are undeniably attractive,
but do they pass the shaved head?
No shirt test.
And if a girl passes the shaved head,
no shirt tests,
that's a ridiculously hot girl,
right?
All these girls in this,
in this montage,
past these shaved head,
no shirt test like this.
I can't say.
I'm surprised.
I'm surprised that granting Harrison,
they're hot,
they're hot.
I'm just a fuck.
They have black eyelashes.
That's what's my point.
It's not even granny hair.
If it's,
if they're that hot take,
it doesn't take on that look like they want to like slow it down a little there
too hot,
you know?
Try to put some roadblocks in the way.
Yeah.
Like it's just,
just too many dudes.
You're hitting on me.
I'm going to fail her to suck his Dick for ready.
I've got too many dicks coming my way.
Did you see that episode of workaholics that they talk about?
That was so fucking good.
I've never watched that show before.
It was hilarious.
Yeah,
I didn't watch it.
I saw some of the clips online,
but I didn't watch it.
And how much of this show is dedicated to making fun of a.
It was a lot.
What happens is they eat pod and throughout the thing they just,
they're quoting you and,
and then.
And then there was some like silly quotes we're going to like know Joe Rogan
says we got to trip on acid and do Jujitsu.
I laughed my ass off.
It's called a pea pod.
It forward,
it's emphasis season five,
episode 12 it.
I've watched it four times.
It's hilarious.
It's a funny show,
man.
I just haven't had a chance to watch it.
Oh,
I barely can keep up with game of thrones.
I don't have time to do anything,
man.
I'm just too fucking busy these days.
We,
seth rogen and all the time we need to Joe Rogan at once in a while.
That's hilarious.
That's an honor.
That's really cool.
When I saw it online,
I was like,
wow,
that's crazy.
It's funny when you go either way,
when you're referenced in the show.
Like I was talking,
I was talking to already laying,
uh,
like two weeks ago or something.
He was,
and he told me that,
uh,
he thought it was an honor,
but you've got a reference on Cleveland show one time,
but it was,
the reference was a,
I guess the,
the mom was buying food one day at a time.
He was like,
nobody buys food one day at a time,
except for already my God.
It's kind of a weird way to have like a punchline.
Shitty.
Yeah.
Let's kind of saying you eat a lot.
You Fuck?
Yeah,
fuck say yeah.
That shows a good show man.
Too.
Funny fucking show.
It's really well written.
It was.
It was surprising because I never had watched it before.
Now that in a broad city,
have you ever watched that?
It's like,
no.
sorry man,
I haven't seen amy Schumer's show either.
I keep hearing really good things about Amy Schumer show.
Have you seen it?
I've watched it.
You know,
the cool thing about broad city,
it's kind of like sex and the city,
but our generation and they just smoke weed and like do gross shit,
but it sounds like sex in the city at all.
It's not city.
It's about two girls and it's just,
you know,
follow the pink pigs.
Hannibal buress.
He plays like a guy in it that's like a real artist and it's,
I,
I highly recommend it.
Damn.
There's so many good shows now,
man.
This is a silicone valley's fucking great.
I've missed a bunch of show then you can't go back to.
There's too many new ones coming out.
Yeah,
if you.
If you're behind,
if you like never watched all the breaking bads,
you can't just start with better call Saul.
You're fucked.
Yeah,
I didn't watch breaking bad.
So yeah,
that's a good hair.
I'm not,
I don't know.
I just don't know.
I watched the first season and it was really good,
but I just kept busy.
It's just a matter of just totally a matter of being busy.
I made through dexter and that got really disappointed at the end.
I gave up on text.
I finished it and it disappointing.
Super disappointed.
Well it got when I talked about this 100 times when John Lithgow killed a
chicken a bathtub and gave her a shitty rear naked choke.
He put her in like a lame rear naked choke.
I'm like,
Piss,
you are not choking anybody with that fuck this show.
And I just,
I literally got rid of the legitimacy of mixed martial arts moves so you can't
just fake.
It's like if you were doing a documentary and Jimi Hendrix and you plant a fake
guitar and you didn't really know what you're doing,
I could tell you didn't know what you're doing.
I go,
fuck this documentary.
You know?
That's how I feel about John Lithgow and his shitty run naked choke.
Plus when you choke somebody,
they fight back like they try.
They try to stay alive.
They're freaking the fuck out.
You don't just stay in place so you could do it.
They fight,
they kicked their legs,
they fucking thrash around.
It looks like Elizabeth Berkley in that coke seen the pool,
which was trying to bang kyle mclachlan.
Whenever she's flying around,
really look like if someone's,
if you're trying to choke somebody,
they would start kicking.
They've realized their life is in danger.
They don't just
join third rock and kill me.
I love you.
And Harry and the Hendersons the fuck Outta here.
He's not a killer.
Stop too much.
You know,
I don't want to typecast the man,
but the fuck out of here.
You didn't like him in that at all that you know.
Oh Wow.
I really did.
Look,
my favorite season to couldn't get past the Shitty Jujitsu technique.
I can't believe that.
I wish they would redo it.
Like Greek or deny it.
Star Wars.
Who shot first or something?
Just a fixed that scene for you?
Nope.
No.
I mean,
was he good?
Other than that,
the show was already know the show.
The show got shitty right from there.
Pretty much what happened.
It was so good at one point in time,
but something happened and it just got really off the rails every year.
They kept exposing like an end of series secret and then.
And then when they get another season they'd have to incorporate that into the
store.
You know what I mean?
So it was like his sister was never supposed to find out he did that and then it
was like multiple seasons of her knowing he was a,
you know what I mean?
Like they got over it very quickly as a cop killed his spoiler alert when it
killed his wife.
When it goes wife,
I was like,
when I think a lot of people always like that,
should've mentioned when John Lithgo killed his wife.
Really?
I didn't know that ups
the ending of that.
Here's the Shitty rear naked choke lit piss poor Jujitsu techniques or you're
not even flexing.
He's not even a flexing.
I just had a bathtub that I could do that in person.
That bathtub.
It'd be way easier to get a bath tub to do that and then to do that.
If you do that,
you have to kill somebody.
Okay.
Do you have a good math?
Yeah.
I'm sure you do.
Good bath.
Yeah.
Get a bath tub,
son.
Hey,
this is America still.
No one's ever said that.
Freestyle from the movie and now who played Biggie and how did this kid was?
Good?
11,
2011 as a four year old movie.
Yeah.
It's been around for a long time.
We're getting here is freestyle.
Oh,
want to hear this
battle?
Stop running.
Stop talking.
Shit.
Whoa.
Oh,
they're angry with each other.
This is really happening.
I don't want to see in the streets and videos can be,
y'all know who killed
Dj on the streets.
Just handed me a microphone in the middle of the street.
Is that.
Let me tell you those stories by the football.
Prepare for like Mr. Clean,
fresh,
like average springs around.
I'm raining and it's coming from the new suite on a mic.
So you might get to play slow jams.
Your
friends talking shit to him.
This was little camp.
Now piggy takes the mind.
Let's hear what he has to say.
I assume it will be better.
Let's start wrapping your what I'm saying.
Shit.
Y'All
niggas want to know how I lived my life.
Making money.
The microphone
close to Salt Lake.
Come step into me.
That's what
comes to mind.
Like Tina Turner
because she will sweep even the guy who's
tended to be big.
He is awesome.
Yeah.
It's just more comfortable to listen to.
It's relaxing.
Well if you listen to like biggie's real shit,
like if you ever seen the video of him freestyling when he was 16 years old,
that's where you got to see Brooklyn.
So go to this,
being able to just spit till that,
go to the Goto Biggie when he was 16 years old.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Oh,
you play this?
God
Damn.
Keep going.
That's 17.
How good was he?
The son,
but freestyle know that there's not sec roast roast jokes,
but how about the fact?
First of all,
it's not freestyle
freestyle.
Those were written rhymes.
He freestyles are.
A lot of them are,
but it's like being able to flow like on the point and then have the right
things to say,
but that's just.
You just got to appreciate what he just did.
Like what?
He just did a microphone.
Old schooling microphone.
Like Chris Rock,
one of those posters.
You Know Lenny Bruce,
those old ones.
He's got one of those.
He's standing on a corner in front of a grocery store on the street and there's
people all around them and there's an actual rap rap battle going on on the
corner.
I mean that.
That's one of the greatest video.
A Korean guy just loading buck shots into a flooded in bedstuy.
That's one of the greatest videos in the history of pop culture.
You want to talk about a talented motherfucker in his environment,
the environment.
When we were,
he developed and grew and you see how good he is and in his hand he's got notes,
stewed and his left hand.
He's got his fucking lyrics,
man.
Most likely look at that.
I mean,
whatever he's holding in his hand.
I would assume that that's probably as notes.
Yeah.
I never even noticed that in the sand before the cash.
It could be cash,
but it's weird shape.
Money.
It's like Bolivian money or some shit.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't look like cash.
Right?
It looks like notes.
It looks like he's got a notepad or maybe it might be one towel.
Yeah,
that's one thing.
He always was sweaty.
He's a bad motherfucker dude.
I mean it's just amazing to see how good his flow was at 17.
He's my all time.
My all time favorite rapper.
That's right there.
Him and Nas.
Nas is like my all time best lyricist.
I think Nas was like the most complex and the most like,
like I would listen to Nas lyrics and girl,
God damn,
this dude's brilliant.
Just brilliant lyrics.
But uh,
you know,
a band that doesn't get enough.
Uh,
a group rather,
it doesn't get enough credit.
Gangstarr doing great dude.
Fuck.
They were amazing.
Gangstarr was this fucking great arena.
Yeah.
Started Locke wrote,
but it was the worst ever.
Nice and smooth.
You remember?
Nice and smooth enough junkies where they use the partridge family song.
Oh,
you've heard that?
No,
I haven't.
Apps and they were nice and smooth world.
If you like a Butthole,
I blocked it out if you like,
um,
gangstarr there.
The song.
Okay.
I might not actually know about this.
They did this song dwek through or,
or.
Well,
I don't know.
Go to.
Sometimes I'm slow sometimes where I'm quick.
You don't remember that.
So I do remember that.
See?
But that's kind of like what year was.
These guys are so not in the mix.
They,
they,
they actually grew old.
No one killed them or nothing.
Doing
fantastic.
401Ks.
Yeah.
What does that say?
Ninety one,
91 man.
I was out of the loop.
That was like when I was struggling hardcore as a comedian dog.
That was three years into my comedy career.
I was doing nothing but doing standup.
I didn't.
I didn't go to any clubs where I would ever hear this.
If you want to chuckle,
play the first verse of Hip Hop Junkies.
It's reasonable about lyrics.
He says everything is nonsequitor.
It's not a cool thing.
He just says words that rhyme there.
That's like zero.
Nothing makes any sense.
Ninety one.
So when I lost my virginity till the audio for the youtube videos,
it doesn't get as these fucks a podcast.
Audio should be able to hear.
Okay.
Do you think nice and smooth?
Does they do drm list for us?
Let's hear this.
No,
I don't hear anything.
We don't hear anything,
so let's give it up.
Oh,
is this in living color is.
Oh Wow.
In living color.
Then I remember this.
Do you remember this down?
Wow.
Okay.
See I went for a period of a few years where I never want.
I watch very little TV.
I didn't watch much pop culture stuff.
I don't know this at all.
Oracle was a great big whale.
I knew a girl who broke the scale.
Man.
Check out the fly girls.
Hmm.
He,
they were sagging.
They were sagging even way back then.
Whoa.
So this is 91.
Shawn Wayans was 20 years from doing an open mic.
Yeah.
How dare you.
He's a nice fellow.
Sw One.
Okay.
You can stop this before we all die.
Die Of fucking shitty music overload.
Black eyes and orange chats.
Remember those days?
Now compare that to big when he was 17.
Place more of that.
Play this.
I bet if black people kept dressing like heavy d or like a different world,
there wouldn't be people getting killed in the street.
It looks like you're just playing golf.
Really stressed.
Like a little kid.
Black Kid.
School sector.
Alright.
No,
come comparison.
I did not like that other stuff's now.
No,
it was horrible.
The worst ever.
I think that's probably the one of the worst rappers ever.
I tried to concentrate on the best.
I try to see the best in things.
Jokers exception of like maybe like,
uh,
didn't like dee dee ramone make a rap album or something like that.
Who's Didi ramone from the ramones?
No Way.
Joey ramone.
Didi Ramone,
yeah.
Do you remember when he was on heroin made a rap?
A rap video?
I thought no.
I'm pretty sure why.
Because he was on heroin.
Heroin,
money.
Didn't Chris Cornell from soundgarden make some really bad pop album?
Like really poppy,
Britney Spears III type music?
I don't know.
What is this?
What are you playing?
Ed?
Kangaroos.
Rap Album.
No Way.
This is Didi ramone.
Let's see.
You see young is what he called himself.
Got to see him.
Stop.
Stop this.
Stop this right now.
Stop talking.
Yeah.
Tim,
do you remember?
Oh my God.
What do you think?
This is like he's being silly.
I mean,
he got up and his place is a mess in this pizza on the floor.
He's lived in that rock and roll lifestyle.
Oh God,
this is awful.
Okay.
Stop it.
Stop at.
What was the other one that we just said?
Oh,
the Chris Cornell stuff that went down.
I remember that.
It was like wild widely decided that that was good,
but he was so fucking good and soundgarden,
it's hard to imagine it was bad in anything,
you know,
listen to blow up the outside world and go look.
That kind of gets a pass forever.
If he can do that,
you know,
you can try all your fucking goofy.
Garth Brooks,
Chris Gaines type projects sometimes that works.
I mean no sugar.
Ray was like a quick speed metal band.
What?
Sugar Ray?
Yeah.
They have a song called mean machine is like,
there was,
there was there one like you know,
sort of radio hit and then they were like,
you're good.
Look at Man,
like cut that hair and frosted tips and Mark Mcgrath.
Yeah.
How did that guy wind up on entertainment?
News reporter has to look at.
He's beautiful to look at,
but he was a really good musician,
but I think he probably wanted to.
I bet he doesn't believe in it.
If your heart heart's probably in the music you don't succeed with if you're.
That happens to you.
So he changed that style of music.
I just want to fly.
I don't think it's what he wanted to,
if you hear his,
the original,
but they have like videos of like the original way the band was and they changed
completely.
I heard incubus did that too though.
I was not.
I didn't know very much before the radio hits,
but like my by my body tells me all the time,
but they were like a pretty like big into psychedelics.
Like psychedelic metal band.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Bus before they did like,
you know,
wish you were here and all that stuff like they already values to with corn and
deaf tone.
They weren't Oz fest before.
What made them change money?
Record executives come in and go,
you're really handsome.
Like clean.
Because he was like a dirt bag to like on God and then he uses.
He's a pretty boy.
Yeah,
they,
everyone knows it was a pretty boy and,
and Oh,
that's weird.
Wow,
that's great that,
that's the untold stories of the music.
Music business to manipulation.
Just like we were talking about movies,
you know,
it's got to be a lot of that in the music business as well.
They're going to make it work.
The beauty and rappers either when they get angry at each other,
they started explaining who had the better childhood.
They started shooting.
You don't talking about what a mother fucker went to private school like that's
always expanding on education.
Remember that was the big thing with it.
I mean eventually got a super exposed,
but Dr Dre,
like right before Nwa was wearing Makino glittery thing.
It was like whatever they there.
I figured they were called.
I just watched that welcome the death row documentary the other day.
That is.
I can't give an Nwa should ignite is just.
That's a scary dude,
man.
Was this sugar ray machine sugary out with original thing was.
Yeah.
Let me hit this.
It's terrible.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It looks weird too.
It's not just just looks.
It looks in the early nineties.
These guys,
someone needs to take them out for a hard night somewhere outside of Orange
County.
Take them out of Laguna beach and bring them to like have really.
They need scars and tattoos and some life experience.
You can't pose a different guys in front of that old Cadillac.
Just stop that.
That does not make you slick.
That's not your car is it?
Is that it's not your fucking car.
For some reason,
I believe like Maroon five was always Maroon five though they've actually
evolved with the times to go towards more popular music.
That does look like the comedy store,
Jamie.
Oh my God.
It is the comedy store,
isn't it?
No,
it's the state that might be.
That's the main room stage.
Do Small.
No,
just with the camera.
It's the angle of the camera,
man.
Holy Shit.
It is also a whole drum kit and it's very possible we'll find out.
No,
it is.
That totally is 100 percent stairs on each side.
I mean if it's not,
it's a very similar design.
Now it's the same dick.
A lot lights inside.
Yeah,
that's it.
I just was full with the camera in.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy.
That comedy store,
main room stage has seen all a lot of shit.
That's what Richard Pryor film live at the sunset strip right at that,
so I'm pretty sure.
Pull that.
Richard Pryor live at the sunset strip.
I think I'm almost positive.
It was filmed at the comedy store.
One of them was filmed at the comedy store.
Right.
There wasn't say the roxy.
Well,
the kinison done one.
The Hbo Special was filmed at the roxy,
you know,
for whatever reason,
probably banned from the comedy store when it went down because he was always
like,
they fucking repaired the bullet hole in the back sign.
I was like,
why did you do that?
Like,
why would you do that?
We'll fix that from Kennison.
Kenny shot a gun in the parking lot to scare dice.
He shot the fucking sign and there was always a bullet hole in it.
I was like,
why would you fix that?
And like,
we didn't know thought was a good idea to fix it.
No,
God damn it.
How could you fix that?
They're like,
well,
there's still the whole in the back of it.
I'm like,
not good enough.
Not good enough.
You need to leave the whole whole,
the whole thing.
Where was it?
Hollywood,
palladium,
palladium on the rest of them.
Carlos,
California.
Well,
wait a minute.
Live on the sunset
was all done at a different place except for one part of it.
That's crazy.
So wasn't on the sunset strip and a year later.
What?
How is that possible?
Two months later.
Wikipedia though.
So I mean it could or how is that possible?
I can get lost on,
on looking at track listing names of comedy.
Albums are always the.
But these aren't so bad,
but sometimes they are just hilarious.
You know?
Did one of the funniest show pull up a video of it.
You know that one of the funniest a track listings that you know Nate Barr,
gatsy.
He's very funny car.
My neighbor gets.
He has a special.
Actually it was on comedy central.
I heard this this last week,
but his album,
the tracks are just called.
It was like,
all right,
good start to get them to.
It's like starting to lose them to how the crowd was reacting to just fucking
pretty high.
That's a funny thing.
Losing them now.
Funny he's up.
Got Him back.
I was like,
got them back.
Did you find it?
It is really weird how the east coast comics in the west coast comics rarely
know each other,
makes us crazy,
so this is.
He probably wore the same suit everywhere and did it a bunch of different
locations,
but decided not to use the ones on the sunset strip for most of the recording.
That's crazy and you can't really tell because he's in a dark stage.
He made it just like a regular show.
That's one thing that was really smart,
like he didn't make the audience all lit up like they do in these new comedy
central specials.
Those motherfuckers are obsessed with lighting the room up.
They want a light everybody up like,
Hey,
fuck head.
That's not how it looks at a comedy show and when you do that,
the audience gets weird.
Like,
see?
Yeah,
you can kind of tell that's not the store.
Yeah.
I don't know why I did think it was.
I haven't seen this in a while.
This'll probably one of the all time greatest comedy document.
I mean,
not probably one of the all time greatest comedy specials ever and just a
documentary as well,
kind of because you're,
you're sort of,
you're looking back into this time and to 1982 when Richard Pryor was on fire.
I mean,
just literally and physically,
right?
This is after he freebasing what do you know?
He did really get burnt and freebase accident said he did lit himself on fire.
The reality is he threw some liquor on him and lit himself on fire.
That's what actually happened to make a steevo way or like,
I'm going to end it all right now.
I'm good.
All right.
Now just,
just down in the deepest,
deepest,
darkest hole after freebasing.
That's why,
um,
he admitted it later,
later in life,
you know,
that he had tried to kill himself,
that he lit himself on fire and they look just after that.
Here he is on stage killing and everybody loved him.
Talk about balance.
I mean,
that's like,
you know,
to be normal and have it goes cohesive thoughts and put those things together
like that.
And then at one point this year or a year or so before this,
you're just in that kind of down that rabbit hole.
Look at backup a little bit.
Jamie.
Backup to that side view of him again.
I want to point
something out here.
Watch the way he moves.
Like pay attention to his hands as he's talking because we can't hear what he's
saying.
Look at the rhythm to the.
He's like doing.
He's putting on a show with his hands,
like while he's performing,
his hands are moving in this delicate controlled way that are.
It's kind of cool to watch and it accentuates the material itself.
It accentuates the joke.
He's moving his hands through the air.
Then it's like,
it's weird to watch.
It's like he's doing a little dance while he's also telling the joke,
his hands going up above his head to emphasize things.
Hands moving around.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
It's performers hands is.
He's just a really great standup.
This is not a guy just standing in front of a microphone talking.
There's a way that he's moving.
That was also funny.
It was like,
it's cool to watch,
like there's a rhythm to the way he would like go and,
and now like he's relaxing you by walking.
He's in between bits,
you know,
and now he's starting another one of the hands start moving again.
It's like he's doing a puppet show or something,
you know,
look at the way he moves.
Like we're not hearing them so we can only see him,
but we can hear the rhythm in the type of material he wasn't doing just by the
way he's moving his hands and there was like,
that was part of what,
what his,
his act was.
It was.
His actual physical movements were funny.
They were vulnerable,
they were,
there were,
there were gentle.
They were rhythmic and they were hypnotic like you could use.
There was a hypnotic aspect to the way he actually moved,
but it doesn't I guess.
I guess not all of them,
but a lot of good comics have that element I think because you have to stay
captivating for all time and then there's the people who get called on like
there for you.
I mean,
that was like the dig on.
I came in comedy at a time where like,
I didn't know Dane Cook enough to be like,
oh that assholes making it,
but there was a lot of around me,
people that,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
he's just hurricane and jerking around on stage and that's all it is and a bunch
of nonsense.
But I was like,
mom,
I think there's something to it.
I mean,
there was definitely an element of what he did with that.
That was something to what he did.
You know what I mean?
I'd be,
I'd be lying if I said Dane Cook and make me laugh.
I man my life through a bunch of stuff.
Will,
a bunch of people enjoyed his movements,
you know?
But there's a thing about that style of comedy and like,
okay,
here's another,
here's a better example,
like emo,
Philips,
Emo,
Philips.
That Shit works when you're 25,
that shit works when you're 35,
but when you're 45 people start going,
hey man,
why you talking like that?
You know,
like why you doing that?
Like what is that that I'm pretending,
especially when that I know,
especially when you pull the curtain and you do interviews and shit.
Like bobcat.
Bobcat had abandoned his,
his early persona.
He's pretty open about that.
He talks about it but his,
you know,
he would,
he would have this crazy wild fucking pulling his hair
and screen and innovate really funny shit it.
Yeah.
And you could watch that one.
I don't know what it was called,
but I remember running into.
We used to when I was younger is that he's wearing like a,
like a sleeveless cowboy shirt almost on the cover of it and he's like super
sweaty and he areas area can tab Kohl's,
but he actually stops doing.
He never announces it just somewhere in the middle of the set.
It just,
that fades away that the character is doing.
Huh?
We'd probably got annoyed with it after awhile and putting it in the middle of
that actual set as well.
I mean he still had the long hair and everything.
It was like a.
He was,
yeah.
Just stops doing in the middle.
Which I thought was interesting was odd,
but when you commit to that character full time at you and you have to worry
about the emo.
Philips is a good example.
I wonder about a Mitch Fatel,
Mitch.
Very much like A.
I mean like I've worked with him and recently it's a.
When you starting to show age on your face,
it's hard to be at the Manchild,
you know what I mean?
It's still tiny guy so it works and everything,
but I just like how long will it like right there.
There might be a very definitive
on that.
Yeah,
like a bomb shelter type ceiling.
Yeah man.
Like the Emo,
Phillips was the big one.
That was a big one because I remember watching him all of a sudden just do
regular standup and I was like,
but I've watched like a transitionary time where he wasn't just doing regular
standup was kind of like doing a softer version of his old self the way he used
to do comedy.
He.
Oh yeah.
So I'm on at midnight doing it,
which was weird.
He was doing it on,
on that show.
He was tall.
He
just very,
very weird.
I mean,
you can't fault that if it works.
Hi Chris Hardwick.
How do you properly dispose a bacon grease?
You gotta throw in the garbage or you know the garbage or.
Yeah,
you can throw it in the garbage.
Not In the pipes.
It's.
Yeah.
Don't throw the pipes.
It's like,
um.
I mean it's like Flash,
you know,
it's like if you aren't going to get rid of fat,
how would you get rid of fat?
Throw it outside.
Yeah,
I mean why would you put it on a tree?
You mean under a tree?
Like it's like fertilizer.
Just dry my dog.
Next.
Turn that shit in the soap.
Like fight club dude bro.
Yo Bro.
These human bodies fight club or something like that was a human fat.
Yeah.
Human fat from a liposuction clinic.
I think you want to fight club to that comic book.
He wrote the book.
Oh,
he just wrote the book.
is it done?
It just came out or it's about to come out here.
Did the cover artwork really?
No Shit.
So are they going to make another movie?
I hope so.
Best movie ever it was.
There's a part two that was so not the best movie I love.
Have you rewatch that horse?
I rewatched.
It was fun.
I liked the movie heat a lot,
but I don't want to heat too.
It's fun up until the moment where you find out that he's the same guy and
you're like,
get the fuck out of here.
That's it.
You watch memento.
Memento is good.
You hate it that you hated the Switcheroo so stupid.
Like,
Oh,
you're the same guy.
Is this guy that you've been falling around and he's been teaching you to fight.
That's you.
You just forgot and now you remember,
oh great,
now you're going to blow up a building or something stupid like the fuck out.
When I've watched it,
I've been convinced to enjoy it much more as a.
But when I saw it in the theater the first time and that was like one of the
first movies in the theater I saw that was like a little odd and different.
You know what I mean?
Like I usually just kind of went saw,
like whatever the blockbusters were.
I was pretty middle of the road on my movie tastes at that age,
but like when I went to go see that,
I was like,
it was so bizarre at the ending.
I just kind of law.
I didn't even get it for me,
I guess it was a safe person,
but I was just like,
there's just like a weird shit at the end of the movie and also for me falls
into that same sort of categories of fake Jimi Hendrix guitar thing.
I'm watching people beat the shit out of each other and like,
look,
nobody wants to fuck beat out of them.
You certainly not going to get a whole basement of dudes willing to beat the
fuck out of each other.
It's just not going to happen.
And then like,
you know,
will die for you.
Let me tell you something.
You get hit once you get really bare knuckled once in the face,
very unlikely you're going to keep doing that.
Very unlikely.
Showing up at work with black eyes all the time.
Like,
really?
Why wouldn't you just learn how to fight it?
A martial arts school?
You fucking idiot.
You got to meet with some asshole in a parking lot.
You guys are going to beat each other's brains out.
You gotta get on top of you.
You're pretty anymore.
Remember that with jared Leto to beat them bloody until his fucking face was can
come on.
That's a good movie.
I.
what'd you feel about.
What'd you feel about?
I thought one of the dumbest scenes to me was,
uh,
when Edward Norton was that 25th hour.
Did you ever see that at the end when he's like,
I can't go and look in this pretty so beat me up.
He goes,
you're going to be pretty again in a couple of weeks.
Was going to buy your butthole like four weeks.
It just go and pretty and fight that guy like to tried to fuck your.
But how stupid is that?
He's that certain.
He's going to get fucked in the ass right away.
I guarantee that some more Hollywood fuckery that some stores has never been
punched and I think you should go and beat up.
He's gonna.
Get his buddy to beat him up.
This is the big term,
mercifully by the way,
it was like a.
It was like a crazy bad.
You lose your vision from those sometimes.
Sometimes you lose.
Your sense of smell is guys lose their tastes.
They can't taste things after they get punched in the head.
It literally don't know what things taste like.
Like this idea that someone's just going to punch you and you just get a little
bruised up a little.
It's not a Charley horse.
Okay.
He's punched in your fucking brain,
punching where you store your brain.
This is the container where your brain's in and it only has so many times.
It could even move like that.
Getting bounced off the curb the fuck out of here.
It's just ridiculous.
The trivialization of brain hemorrhaging and brain trauma and beat downs like
that.
It's like,
I can't go along with that.
I know too much.
I've seen too many people get the fucking brains beaten out of them.
I've seen it too many times,
so I didn't like fight club,
but I didn't like it.
You like warrior?
Yes,
but it was bullshit.
You can't fight two days in a row,
you just can't be so fucked up from the first fight.
No one gets
fired back to back.
Yes.
I would take back in one day.
Any day over that.
Well,
I think fight club is a better movie than warrior is definitely a better as a
movie.
Well better,
much better movie.
It's just that,
that one reveal I can almost deal with the idea that these guys like were filled
with angst so much.
They were wanting to beat each other up just so they could feel alive.
I could kind of get that for a little bit,
but.
No,
no,
no one had any technique,
no one that doesn't make any sense to me that guys wouldn't actually learn how
to fight sweet little titties.
Um,
but uh,
what was I gonna say?
Um,
you bought into the fact that they were just at the turnaround,
the flip,
the,
the reveal that it was the same guy was just so dumb and if it gets cold,
you can't pretend that he was just,
Oh,
it was just a dream to make your whole movies based on like a switcheroo.
Like the whole movie is a big switcheroo.
Did not see that latest episodes of grey's anatomy.
Then when.
Mr. Don't worry about that.
You do a Switcheroo oh there's that thousand horrible switcher in that you do
not have to worry about me watching.
That's what the,
the ending of Dexter.
No,
just to the shittiest thing of all time.
Don't do it to me so much.
I can't do it.
It was horrible.
Well that was one of the things that I really appreciated about the movie is
there's none of that.
Every scene in that movie.
Did you see it now?
I'm seeing a jamie.
You saw tomorrow.
That's fucking bad ass.
It's so smart.
It's so well done that you buy every step of the way.
Like there's never one part in the movie.
We like get the fuck outta here because they're dark flick.
It's good dude.
It's good.
It's creepy.
It's like it puts you in a position like,
fuck.
I don't know man.
It's,
it's about A.
I can't tell you bitch.
It's about Ai.
It's pretty.
It's pretty fucking good man.
Like one of the best movies I've seen in many years.
Have you seen this?
Elon Musk,
the tesla firewall,
this new,
very affordable solar power battery that he's invented.
There's 3,500 bucks.
They could charge a fucking whole house.
Wow.
A total game changer.
Have you seen this shit,
Jamie?
It's incredible.
There's a video,
if you go on.
My twitter feed is a video that I retweeted that somebody sent me a youtube
video of him explaining it.
It's a fucking complete total game changer when it comes to batteries and a wall
mounted units.
You can stack as many as nine of these wall mounted units.
That 3,500 bucks,
which is solar power,
was like really prohibitively expensive for most people.
Like super,
super expensive.
Those batteries,
the techs all fucked up.
They stink.
They're all they overheat.
They're dangerous,
but apparently this fucking dude is nailed it.
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm obviously not a fucking expert on batteries,
but people are very,
very excited about this fucking thing.
That cars.
We'll take our air corps to go Baltimore.
Yeah.
Give us some volume.
We'll close out with this because we've got to get the fuck out of here.
Twenty minutes long will give us just a little bit of volume here.
Jamie.
Play a little bit of.
It was a beautiful man.
Beautiful Iron man type motherfucker.
We call the Tesla powerwall and if you look back against that wall,
you'll see a whole bunch of them as well in different colors.
How long for this guy makes an iron man suit?
You can pick your favorite color.
He's Ironman
and it looks like a beautiful sculpture on the wall.
So it's very important.
I want to point out a few things that are very important about this.
Um,
the fact that it's wall mounted is,
is vital because it means you don't need to have a battery room.
He don't have to have some room filled with nasty batteries.
It means that a normal household can mount this on their garage or on the
outside wall of their house and it doesn't take up any room.
It's,
it's.
I mean it's flat against the wall.
It,
it has all of the integrated safety systems,
the incredibles
dcdd
design.
Something
like this guy is like a guy in a movie.
It,
it addresses all the needs,
so watch that.
Folks,
do you want to watch because we're out of time here,
but this guy's like a guy in the movie.
He's like a super billionaire genius inventor from a movie mean makes a car that
everybody falls in love with.
It's got a God damn laptop in the middle of it.
You ever seen those?
Yeah.
My friend got one.
It's amazing.
There's no,
there's no feeling of shift at all.
It's just this acceleration.
There's a new one that comes out next year though.
That's going to be a lot better.
I heard.
Well she forgot.
I don't know if it's next year.
His a new tesla or tesla.
We had a new model that he gave you that's unbelievably fast.
Zero to 60 in like three something seconds.
All Electric,
all electric,
but they still can't go to vegas.
Still can't go to vegas.
Why?
You have to stop.
Stopped halfway there and charge up in the middle of fucking desert at some
creep.
Head fucking Weirdos.
Stop where you plug in and you got to wait for half an hour while they circle
you like buzzards because they know you can't go anywhere.
Hey man,
you can't even drive with that right now.
If you gone drive with that and right now,
how far do you think you get?
How long does it last?
You might get 350 miles out of a tank.
You know,
a charge rather.
You might.
But if you're driving fast you won't be driving fast.
Is gonna eat it?
I'm usually more having a bunch of apps open.
Yeah,
it's going to eat it up.
So like when it starts slowing a DMZ inside lights does all the shit do a.
like Aubrey has won the almost almost died out on his way home one night because
he left it at his office.
And when you leave it somewhere,
it slowly drains the battery.
Yeah.
Like you can't leave it and just go away for three weeks and come back to fully.
It'll be typed up.
Battery.
It'll be hurting having your iphone and just leaving it on the kitchen table for
a week.
Leaving it on.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because it's also,
it's also an iphone,
like a.
not like a cell phone.
It's got a three g connection,
only three g,
which is wack.
But it's constantly connected to the Internet.
So like you could say google a flock of seagulls and it'll pull up flock of and
you'll start play
flock of seagulls and we'll give you some options and you just start with a far
as streaming,
like out of nowhere.
That's what I would have picked this.
I know.
That's why I said it.
I knew it was your shit man.
What is your shit?
If you have,
if you're going to talk to your Tesla,
what would you tell it?
Where you.
Where your punisher shirt?
Oh Man.
It depends.
Depends on the mood.
Quite honestly be.
It could be metal,
it could be a
little river band,
bunch of goofy like soft rock hits if you want to say eighties music or rap or
whatever.
You see a really bad movie.
See the Dolph Lundgren version of the punisher
movie.
I went to theater for that.
Did you ever see the short.
They did a with Thomas j Dot Thomas.
Janet.
Here's it's even better.
It's so bad and it's low resolution back then.
Right?
And so they.
He couldn't grow a beard and the punisher had to have a beard,
so they smudge makeup on his face to pretend it's a beard.
See and pull it up and we'll end with this because we'll.
We'll get a nice hardy man.
Laughs.
It was all three of us can grow an actual beard.
Look at this.
Pussy is Dolph Lundgren.
Meanwhile,
he's a stud.
Bruce Jenner,
rogers chance proof.
Sharing their personal understanding.
Yeah.
Bruce.
Janet has it all lasered off.
Fuck can I say my podcast before everyone gets made at using skank because we
just gangs and the Sdr shows on all things.
Comedy was same as what is the sdrs show,
sex,
drugs,
and rock and roll.
She's interviewed Porn Stars and rock stars.
You guys are crazy,
but we ended some interview Tesla,
but not that guy.
The band.
Tesla.
My best to kind of interviews.
We do.
It's fun.
Very Fun.
Is it available on itunes?
All of them available on itunes.
All available on itunes.
A Sdr show is on all things comedy.
See if you could go back to see if you find a good picture of his face,
like a google image because it's so stupid.
He couldn't.
Oh,
I guarantee you.
There's one.
Look at this fucking smudgy.
There we go there.
It's so vague.
It's like fake beard on.
It's like a really.
No,
that's not ed second.
Well,
it's funny if you see the one where he's at,
the bullets on his chest like you can see when it's too light that he has no
beard at all.
It's.
It's hard to tell a little bit there.
That may be pissed me off.
He's like a 12 year old Cuban kid.
Will you be so good at your as Drago though?
He was so good as drug.
Yeah,
and that's what the punisher would have looked like.
Presenting Hillston was so good as Mrs Drago and she fucks flavor flavor
eventually.
So you know,
we all have our ups and downs,
peaks and valleys.
You all.
We're going to end with that because that shit's real as fuck.
Again,
cheap meals and remember too that she used to be smoking copas Wednesday night.
The comedy store is ridiculous.
Show.
Yeah.
We got Sarah Silverman,
you,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
brody Stevens,
and a bunch of surprise people,
but May 12th San Francisco at the punchline with Tony and May,
13th in Sacramento.
Tickets are on sale@punchlinecomedyanddeathsquad.tv
for all the dates if you don't remember it,
and a red band on twitter.
If you want to just do you have your up on your,
your
itunes or you're to the right eye toward a death squad dot t dot j Dot Wilkerson
cloud.
We could do it again and thanks for having [inaudible] a man.
Anytime you're in town,
let me know and we'll hook it up and keep doing it.
Always a good time,
my friend,
uh,
again,
follow big Jay Oakerson on twitter,
um,
website,
a big j comedy.com.
Big J comedy.
You fucks.
All right.
Love you guys.
Talk to you soon.
Many,
many more podcasts this week.
See you.
Bye.
Yeah.